It's been a minute, it's been a minute since we've been able to kind of wrap just us without the other guys and it's really important to me for you guys to know how important you guys are to me because the success of SmartList has all just been because of you, the listener. So I'm always just looking to put you guys first, oh my god, I really gotta take this you guys. Hello? I have not renewed my warranty, why? Welcome to SmartList. The only time this guy's on first is when it's his guest, otherwise you're late, you're chewing. I did a lot of chewing before I just finished. Do you have respect for this guest? I do have respect for this guest, yeah, a lot. Really? Yes, on a lot of levels. Well, we'll see.
好久不见，我们已经很久没有像这样只有我们几个人，没有其他人在场了。对我来说，让你们知道你们对我有多重要真的很重要，因为SmartList的成功完全归功于你们，也就是听众。所以我总是想把你们放在第一位，天哪，我真的得接这个电话。喂？我还没续保，为什么？欢迎来到SmartList。这家伙只有在嘉宾是他请的时候才会准时，不然你总是迟到，还在嚼东西。我刚才嚼了很多东西才吃完。你尊重这位嘉宾吗？我确实尊重这位嘉宾，是的，在很多层面上。真的吗？是的，在很多层面上。好吧，我们走着瞧。
Yes. Hi, Sean clearly does not have respect for this guest. Hi Sean. Hi Will, how are you? I'm good, are you having some sugar and milk? I am actually. What are you having with it? Just a little bit of drop of tea. I sent Jason this thing. By the way, you haven't had your father-in-law, Paul Anko on the show yet. It's embarrassing. Well, I was thinking about that. I was at dinner with him last night and then I thought maybe one of you guys, I feel like Michael Granteri, our incredible producer, is working on that and that it's a scheduling thing. I feel like we have officially gone out to him. Yeah, I feel like it's so good to watch him wriggle. It's amazing. I feel like we've gone out to him when you had dinner with him last night.
是的。嗨，肖恩显然不尊重这位嘉宾。嗨，肖恩。嗨，威尔，你好吗？我很好，你在喝加糖加奶的茶吗？确实是。你配着什么吃？就加了一点点茶。我给杰森发了这个东西。顺便说一句，你还没请你的岳父保罗·安卡上节目呢。这太尴尬了。嗯，我一直在考虑这件事。我昨晚和他一起吃晚饭，然后我想也许你们中的一个人，我觉得我们出色的制片人迈克尔·格兰特里正在处理这件事，这只是个时间安排问题。我觉得我们已经正式向他发出邀请了。是的，我觉得看他局促不安的样子真好。太棒了。我觉得在你昨晚和他吃晚饭的时候，我们就已经向他发出邀请了。
I know, you could have just said, hey, I feel like it's a schedule. He was very excited to hear that you're a Canadian. I'm surprised you didn't know that already. Yeah, me neither. I sent you and your wife a nice email about him and about the inspiration for his song, Diana, which was a huge hit, which you wrote when he was like 16. 16? Is this the guest? No, no, no, it's Paul Anko. Paul went down to New York and recorded all these tunes, these huge hits. You know, he wrote My Way amongst other great things in that song. Diana, he was 16 years old. Isn't that crazy? Yeah. And he wrote about this woman who she just recently passed away and she claimed that it dogged her for her whole life. I'm like, yeah, it's pretty cool to have Paul Anko write a song.
我知道，你本可以直接说，嘿，我觉得这是个时间安排问题。他听说你是加拿大人时非常兴奋。我很惊讶你竟然不知道这一点。是的，我也不知道。我给你和你妻子发了一封关于他的好邮件，关于他那首热门歌曲《戴安娜》的灵感来源，那是他16岁时写的。16岁？这是嘉宾吗？不，不，不，是保罗·安卡。保罗去了纽约，录制了所有这些曲子，这些巨大的热门歌曲。你知道，他写了《My Way》以及其他伟大的作品。写《戴安娜》时他才16岁。这不疯狂吗？是的。他写的是一个最近刚去世的女人，她声称这首歌困扰了她一生。我觉得，能让保罗·安卡写一首歌真是太酷了。
It is. You know when I was 16 years old? I was going to ask you. I was going to get through this. Yeah, go ahead. Yeah. Go ahead, Sean. I was in shoplifting skittles. No, I did shoplift something when I was, I took, I stole a turkey sandwich when I was in college and got arrested for it. Jesus. But anyway, in, when I was 16, I was in my room and I listened to Wham and I listened to like Wham Rap and I would try, I memorized all the lyrics. Shocker. I mean, I mean, Sean, this is- And I'm in my room like acting like I'm in Wham and I learned all the words and my mom completely walked in on me and caught me, you know, and then you cover like, oh no, I was just cleaning my room like it was so embarrassing. And she saw you because she was, she came in on the right side.
确实。你知道我16岁的时候在干什么吗？我正要问你。我正要说这个。是的，继续。是的。继续，肖恩。我在商店里偷彩虹糖。不，我确实在大学时偷过东西，我偷了一个火鸡三明治，结果被捕了。天哪。但不管怎样，16岁时，我在房间里听威猛乐队（Wham!）的歌，听像《Wham Rap》之类的，我试着背下所有的歌词。真让人震惊。我是说，我是说，肖恩，这……而且我在房间里假装自己是威猛乐队的一员，我学会了所有的歌词，我妈妈完全闯了进来，抓住了我，你知道，然后你掩饰说，哦不，我只是在打扫房间，这太尴尬了。她看见你了，因为她是从右边进来的。
She had her head till turn to the right. The door cracked open just one eye looked at. And you were doing Wham because you hadn't learned Frankie goes to Hollywood lyrics yet? Or what's going on? You just wanted to go through all the different. George, George, Michael and Andrew Richfield. Rich Lee. Rich Lee. Rich Lee. Rich Lee. Yeah. Rich Lee. It was kind of like, it was kind of like- Look how mad Sean get when he said, Rich Lee. God, I hope that's a surprise guest today. Andrew Rich. Guys, you have Andrew Rich Lee on. Jason wanted me to tell you about my nerve thing, but maybe I'll do that in the next show. I wanted to tell you, you wanted to tell me what? You wanted me to tell Will about my neck procedure. I did. Oh yeah. I definitely want to
她把头转向右边。门开了一条缝，只有一只眼睛往里看。而你当时在模仿威猛乐队，因为你还没学会“弗兰基去好莱坞”（Frankie Goes to Hollywood）的歌词？还是怎么回事？你只是想把所有不同的乐队都过一遍？乔治，乔治·迈克尔和安德鲁·里奇利。里奇利。里奇利。里奇利。是的。里奇利。这有点像……看看肖恩在说“里奇利”时有多生气。天哪，我希望今天有个惊喜嘉宾。安德鲁·里奇利。伙计们，你们请到了安德鲁·里奇利。杰森想让我告诉你们关于我的神经问题，但也许我会在下一期节目中说。我想告诉你，你想告诉我什么？你想让我告诉威尔关于我的颈部手术的事。我确实想。哦，是的。我绝对想
hear about that. Let me carve out some time. I can hear about your neck issues. Speaking of time, Did I say that at the party the other night? No, you said it like you should two weeks ago. Speaking of time, we don't have a ton of time because we've already started late. Okay, yeah. I was late, sorry. And Jason was right. I was a little, I'm a little bit, I'm very excited about our guests. You know, as you think about an intro and how you introduce somebody, you think about what they've done. And I thought about this for a long time and where you start because, you know, we often have guests on who wear a lot of different hats. And, but they start somewhere, but then they do other things and they're sometimes it's a hobby,
听听那个。让我腾出点时间。我可以听听你的颈部问题。说到时间，我那天晚上在派对上说过吗？不，你两周前就该说了。说到时间，我们没有太多时间了，因为我们已经迟到了。好的，是的。我迟到了，抱歉。杰森是对的。我有点，我有点，我对我们的嘉宾感到非常兴奋。你知道，当你考虑开场白以及如何介绍某人时，你会想到他们做过什么。我考虑了很久，从哪里开始，因为，你知道，我们经常请到身兼数职的嘉宾。而且，他们从某个地方开始，但后来他们做了其他事情，有时这是一种爱好，
but sometimes it's, you know, something that they might be good at. Our guest today is someone who has started almost in concert their art and their, their art was informed by what they saw in the world around them. And it drove their art to incredible heights. But in that time, there was always this message about what was going on in the world around him. And he along with his three bandmates created a band together when they were very young. That was again, just always a reflection of what they saw and what they felt in the world. And then they didn't just do that and just let it be part of their art. It's almost like their activism became part of their art. And they didn't just lend their name or write a check and
但有时，你知道，这是他们可能擅长的事情。我们今天的嘉宾是一个几乎在艺术创作的同时就开始了他们事业的人，他们的艺术受到他们周围世界所见所闻的影响。这推动他们的艺术达到了令人难以置信的高度。但在那段时间里，总是有关于他周围世界正在发生的事情的信息。他和他的三位乐队成员在很年轻的时候就组建了一个乐队。这再次反映了他们所见所感。然后他们并没有就此打住，让它仅仅成为艺术的一部分。几乎可以说他们的行动主义成为了他们艺术的一部分。他们不仅仅是借出名字或写张支票，
wave and say, I gave, they went and got in the trenches. This person has been around the world, whether it's fighting poverty and fighting hunger. This person, I think maybe no single soul human has ever done more to raise awareness and, and money and, and serve as an agency for change in the fight against AIDS. And all of that sort of in a lot of ways kind of it almost overwhelms what a great artist he is. This person is, it's so hard. I can't even, I'm just, I'm just bubbling to get it out because he'll tell you everything. He's got a new book out that just came out called Surrender. Guys, it's Bono. Oh, yeah. It's Elton John, actually. Bob Gelluff, you know, Sean Penn, Julie Roberts. Wow. Oh my God. What an honor to have you join us.
挥挥手说，我捐了，他们亲自深入一线。这个人走遍了世界各地，无论是对抗贫困还是对抗饥饿。我认为，可能没有哪个人在提高意识、筹集资金以及作为艾滋病斗争的变革推动者方面做得更多。所有这些在很多方面几乎掩盖了他是一位多么伟大的艺术家。这个人，太难了。我甚至，我只是，我只是迫不及待地想说出来，因为他会告诉你一切。他有一本刚出版的新书叫《Surrender》。伙计们，是波诺（Bono）。哦，是的。其实是埃尔顿·约翰。鲍勃·格尔多夫，你知道，肖恩·潘，朱莉娅·罗伯茨。哇。天哪。非常荣幸你能加入我们。
My goodness. I have been such a huge fan of yours for so, so long. This is crazy. So long. Do you know just like three weeks ago or four weeks ago, I had dinner with, and forgive me, I don't know if I say the edge or just edge. That will do. Okay. That's just the, just the, uh-huh. And he was, I was picking his, I can't believe I'm, by the way, it's such an honor to meet you. A huge fan. I mean, Joshua Tree was like a huge part of my life in high school. It was just massive. And anyway, I was talking to the about that and at dinner and he was singing your praises as of course you would expect, but he was explaining how the, how different you both are. And that's what makes part of the whole band work is that you're, you know, he doesn't like the spotlight.
天哪。我一直是你的超级粉丝，太久太久了。这太疯狂了。太久了。你知道就在三周或四周前，我和，请原谅我，我不知道该叫“The Edge”还是只叫“Edge”。叫Edge就行。好的。那就是，只是，嗯哼。我当时在向他请教，我不敢相信，顺便说一句，见到你真是太荣幸了。我是超级粉丝。我是说，《约书亚树》（Joshua Tree）是我高中生活的重要组成部分。它太震撼了。不管怎样，我在晚餐时和他在谈论那个，他当然在称赞你，正如你所预料的那样，但他解释了你们俩是多么不同。这就是让整个乐队运作的原因，因为你，你知道，他不喜欢聚光灯。
He likes to be in the back. He likes to play like, he almost doesn't like to be even seen. And I thought it was fascinating. And he also said that what, sorry, I'm almost done. This is one of those moments I wish Sean was at a loss for words, but he's not. Okay, go ahead. He also said, I said, Joshua Tree was such a huge part of my life in high school. Tell me about how that happened. And he said, you know, during the time of Madonna and Michael Jackson and George Michael and all these kinds of amazing people in their own right, you guys came along with this kind of out of left field, this band that was just the timing was perfect for you guys. And that's also what helped make that album so huge. It was, it was just another, the,
他喜欢待在后面。他喜欢演奏，就像，他几乎不喜欢被看见。我觉得这很迷人。他还说，什么，抱歉，我快说完了。这是那种我希望肖恩词穷的时刻，但他没有。好吧，继续。他还说，我说，《约书亚树》是我高中生活的重要组成部分。告诉我那是怎么发生的。他说，你知道，在麦当娜、迈克尔·杰克逊和乔治·迈克尔以及所有这些了不起的人的时代，你们带着这种出人意料的风格出现了，这个乐队的时机对你们来说太完美了。这也是让那张专辑如此巨大的原因。它只是另一个，
the option that wasn't out there. Huh. At the end of all that, not even a question mark. No. Well, I think what you're saying, Sean, and by the way, there's an altar for you in Dingle in Southern Ireland, just so you know, yeah, yeah, there's an altar there. Yeah, we brought a bit of black and white to these very, these people are very colorful and very vivid. And we arrived in Anton Corbin photography, very, very black and white facts. So black and white that our manager, Paul McGinnis used to say, now don't look like the band too stupid to enjoy being at number one now, will you? But yeah, the decade taste forgot was very good to us.
当时不存在的选择。哈。最后连个问号都没有。不。嗯，我想你是在说，肖恩，顺便说一句，在爱尔兰南部的丁格尔有一个为你准备的祭坛，你知道的，是的，是的，那里有一个祭坛。是的，我们给这些非常多彩和生动的人带来了一点黑白。我们带着安东·寇班的摄影作品到达，非常非常黑白的现实。黑白到我们的经理保罗·麦吉尼斯常说，现在别表现得像个笨到不知道享受排名第一的乐队，好吗？但确实，被时代遗忘的十年对我们非常好。
And I'm very, very grateful. And Edge is indeed a kind of anti guitar hero, which is, you know, he, I mean, he's like the most extraordinary person for getting guitar player, genius, probably the most influential guitar player the last 30 years. The only one who won't tell you is him. And yeah, it's good to get time with him there, Sean. I always treasure it when I get time with him. And he only lives 100 years from where I'm sitting right now. In fact, he called me just before I came on. He was singing your praises as, of course. So, Bono, about that sort of opposites, and I'm sure that's an exaggeration, but clearly there are some different lanes that each one of you four occupy in the, in the band slash family.
我非常非常感激。Edge确实是一种反吉他英雄，你知道，他，我是说，他是最非凡的吉他手，天才，可能是过去30年最有影响力的吉他手。唯一不会告诉你这一点的人就是他自己。是的，能和他在一起待一会儿真好，肖恩。我总是珍惜和他在一起的时间。而且他住的地方离我现在坐的地方只有100年远。事实上，我上节目之前他刚给我打过电话。他当然在称赞你。所以，波诺，关于那种对立面，我相信这是一种夸张，但显然你们四个人在乐队兼家庭中占据着不同的轨道。
And Jason loves lanes. You love lanes. I love a lane. I love a bucket. No, I don't actually don't do buckets. Buckets is overdone today or silos. But talk to us about how you guys manage those dynamics where everyone kind of has their lane, but then there's good overlap sometimes when you guys need to collaborate. Is it something that you guys keep an eye on so that the harmony literally and figuratively stays intact? Yeah. Well, I mean, look, I, from the podcast, I have overheard, plugged into, enjoyed, you're obviously a band, too. It's a power trio. Isn't that your things like cream or the police or nirvana? Don't be rush. But progressive rock is actually one of the only things myself and edge fall out over. But yeah, being in a band, it's, it's,
杰森喜欢轨道。你喜欢轨道。我喜欢桶。不，我其实不喜欢桶。桶在今天被过度使用了，或者说筒仓。但跟我们谈谈你们是如何管理这些动态的，每个人都有自己的轨道，但有时当你们需要合作时，会有很好的重叠。这是你们会留意的事情吗，为了让和谐在字面上和比喻上都保持完整？是的。嗯，我是说，看，从播客里，我偷听过，插播过，享受过，你们显然也是一个乐队。这是一个强力三人组。这不是你们的东西吗，像Cream、The Police或Nirvana？别提Rush。但前卫摇滚其实是我和Edge唯一会产生分歧的事情。但确实，在一个乐队里，这，
it's tricky. And, and the older you get, you know, it gets even trickier because when you grow up together, you're used to taking bits out of each other, you know, and it's, because people know where you've come from, you know, they know, they know your memories. I think that's the best definition I heard of really knowing someone is you know their memories, you know how they got them. And so they will remind you, the band will remind you of how far away from yourself you've gotten. And at a certain point, people don't want to be reminded of that, you know, and I'm always amazed that we're still together because, you know, it is, it's rough. I mean, you're as good as the arguments you get. But at a certain point when people are doing well, the male loves to be the
这很棘手。而且，你年纪越大，你知道，它就越棘手，因为当你一起长大时，你习惯于从对方身上索取，你知道，这是因为人们知道你来自哪里，你知道，他们知道你的记忆。我认为这是我听过的关于真正了解某人的最好定义，就是你知道他们的记忆，你知道他们是如何获得这些记忆的。所以他们会提醒你，乐队会提醒你，你已经偏离自己有多远了。在某个时刻，人们不想被提醒这一点，你知道，我总是很惊讶我们还能在一起，因为，你知道，这很艰难。我是说，你有多好取决于你经历的争论。但在某个时刻，当人们做得很好时，男性喜欢成为
Lord of his own domain, you know, and you can just imagine why people say, ah, fuck this, I'm out of here. I mean, I'm really genuinely expected. And the band breaks up all the time. It's the truth. We just don't announce it. And then we get back together. You just never fall. You can't be very grateful. We do. You can't be fucked to follow through on it. Well, you know what? It's funny you say that, Bono, because I, so your book, I mentioned that your book has come out and you've been on tour supporting it. You, you've done, you did a date and, and now you're announcing that you're going to go on tour and do some more dates, which is so excellent. And so I read parts of your book
自己领域的主宰，你知道，你可以想象为什么人们会说，啊，去他的，我不干了。我是说，我真的真诚地期待着。乐队一直在解散。这是事实。我们只是不宣布而已。然后我们又聚在一起。你永远不会倒下。你不能太感激。我们确实。你没法去执行它。嗯，你知道吗？波诺，你说得很有趣，因为我，所以你的书，我提到你的书已经出版了，你一直在巡回宣传它。你，你做了一个日期，现在你宣布你要去巡演并做更多的日期，这太棒了。所以我读了你书的一部分
all the way through. And actually I, I heard that somebody told me that that's kind of how you want people to do it, kind of dipping it out. So I 40 short stories. It works. I've constructed it as 40 short stories as well as the sort of beginning middle and end arc. Yeah. And so the chapter, and there's pictures as well, special pictures, you know, little drawings for you. Well, they're drawings that made it much easier. That would be a, it was a pop-up book. I just stared at them. These guys, I have to explain what a book is to them, but you should know. So Bono, but you, you talk about you guys breaking up. So you start, you guys get to know each other when you're very young,
一直读完。其实我，我听说有人告诉我，这正是你希望人们做的方式，有点像蘸着读。所以我写了40个短篇故事。它行得通。我把它构建成40个短篇故事，以及某种开始、中间和结束的弧线。是的。所以这一章，还有图片，特别的图片，你知道，给你的小画。嗯，是那些让它变得容易得多的画。那会是一个，它是一本立体书。我只是盯着它们看。这些家伙，我得向他们解释什么是书，但你应该知道。所以波诺，但你，你谈到你们解散。所以你开始，你们在很年轻的时候就认识了，
you meet through mutual friends, you're very, and, and, and not, not only do you guys know about each other, this is what I was getting to, but the world knows as, as what you guys have grown up together and you've grown up in a world and the world has watched you guys grow up together. And it's funny, you mentioned a few times in the book, the home in which you grew up, 10 Cedarwood Road. And I got to the point, I'm almost embarrassed to say that I, I googled it on Google Maps because I wanted to look and I wanted to kind of get a feel of it as, as I was reading it, you know, your descriptions of jumping around in the living room, listening to the Ramones and your dad coming home and you being there with Ali and all these various sort of anecdotes you
你们通过共同的朋友认识，你们非常，而且，而且，不仅你们了解彼此，这就是我要说的，但世界知道，因为你们一起长大，你们在一个世界里长大，世界看着你们一起长大。很有趣，你在书中提到了几次，你长大的家，雪松木路10号。我到了那个点，我几乎不好意思说，我在谷歌地图上搜索了它，因为我想看一看，我想在阅读时感受一下，你知道，你描述在客厅里跳来跳去，听雷蒙斯乐队的歌，你爸爸回家，你和阿里在那里，以及所有这些你
had that really were such a window into your life and all these different stages. And as I put it in Google, it says Bonovox childhood house. And I thought fucking Google knows that that's where you grew up. The world knows, the world knows a lot of your memories. But just on the outside, and now you're sharing all of this stuff from the inside. How, how is the experience of writing this book and kind of bearing it all in a way? It's called surrender. So did it feel like that? I'm still, that's still a word I'm ganging up on having to fully grasp or fathom the title of my own book. But I, yeah, you know, I really, I decided to go there and it's, you know, go all the way. It's not a confessional, but it is kind of anatomical. And if you want to
有的各种轶事，它们确实是你生活和所有这些不同阶段的一扇窗。当我把它放进谷歌时，它显示“波诺童年故居”。我想，该死的谷歌知道那是你长大的地方。世界知道，世界知道你的很多记忆。但只是在外面，现在你正在分享所有这些来自内部的东西。写这本书以及以某种方式承担这一切的经历如何？它叫《Surrender》（投降）。所以感觉是那样吗？我仍然，那仍然是一个我正在努力完全掌握或理解我自己的书名的词。但我，是的，你知道，我真的决定去尝试，而且，你知道，全力以赴。这不是忏悔录，但它确实有点解剖学意义。如果你想
see the band in a rehearsal room or in the studio or the sort of the struggles around it with each other and with the world around us, I'm going to write about it in a still cross section, same as an activist, the same in other areas of my life, my family life. I just decided to go there. And then I said, I'll afterwards decide if I publish it. And then I would get caught in it. And I find myself the real value of writing a book like this is you sort of retrieve memories from the kind of river, from you drudge them, some out of the sewer, but you know, you find them. And, and that's beautiful, even the one about my father coming home. And I just brought Ali Stewart. I just brought her home. And I was showing her my little box room. And I swear I wasn't in bed
在排练室或录音室里看到乐队，或者看到它与彼此以及与我们周围世界的某种挣扎，我会写下它，就像一个行动主义者，在我生活的其他领域，我的家庭生活也是一样。我只是决定去尝试。然后我说，我事后再决定是否出版。然后我会沉浸其中。我发现写这样一本书的真正价值在于，你从某种河流中检索记忆，你从下水道里拖出一些，但你知道，你找到了它们。而且，这很美，即使是关于我父亲回家的那个。我刚带阿里·斯图尔特回家。我正在向她展示我的小箱子房。我发誓我没在床上
with her. I was on the bed with her. And it was the one time my father came home in the middle of the day, it was Wednesday. And he's like, are you in there? What are you doing home? I said, it's a half day. And he goes, what? I said, what are you doing home? I can do what I like. And then he I heard him coming up the stairs. And I'm like, Ali, what are we going to do? And she's looking at me. I say panic. She said, I'm not going to panic. I said, get under the bed. And she's like, what? I've nothing to be ashamed. Get under the bed. So she gets under the bed. And the dark comes and he goes, you know, um, are you okay? And I'm like, don't be that this is not going to be the day that he asks me how I am doing existentially. And, and then he comes in and he sits on the bed. Oh, God. So
和她在一起。我和她在床上。那是我父亲在一天中间回家的一次，那是星期三。他说，你在里面吗？你在家干什么？我说，这是半天假。他说，什么？我说，你在家干什么？我可以做我想做的事。然后我听到他走上楼梯。我说，阿里，我们该怎么办？她看着我。我说，恐慌。她说，我不会恐慌。我说，钻到床底下。她说，什么？我没什么好羞耻的。钻到床底下。所以她钻到了床底下。黑暗降临了，他说，你知道，嗯，你还好吗？我说，别这样，今天不是他问我存在主义上过得如何的日子。然后他进来了，坐在床上。哦，天哪。所以
Ali has two usans on top of her. And she's going to stay that way for quite some time. But if I hadn't written the book, I wouldn't have remembered that. I wouldn't be talking to you about it now and the stuff with my mother, you know, because I lost my mother in an early age. I just I found all these, I found her. And, and then with the show that you mentioned, you know, the half man show, we call it in the band. It's not even a one man show. And I'm, I'm finding that I'm spending time with my father, my mother, because I kind of become my father as part of the show. And I'm starting to, I mean, I always loved him, but I'm starting to like him, which is mad. As I become him in the show, I, I take his voice and I, and I'm, he made me laugh. He's made me laugh a lot.
阿里身上有两个成年人。她要在那儿待上一段时间。但如果我没写这本书，我就不会记得那个了。我现在就不会和你谈论它了，还有关于我母亲的事情，你知道，因为我在很小的时候就失去了母亲。我只是，我找到了所有这些，我找到了她。然后是你提到的那个节目，你知道，半人秀，我们在乐队里这样称呼它。这甚至不是一个人的表演。我发现我正在花时间和我的父亲、母亲在一起，因为我在节目中有点变成了我的父亲。我开始，我是说，我一直爱他，但我开始喜欢他了，这很疯狂。当我在节目中变成他时，我，我采用了他的声音，我，他让我笑。他让我笑了很多。
So the book has given me a lot, I will say that. So thank you. You talk about it in the book again about your relationship with your dad in, in about that moment when you're in the chapel and as, and you, and you, you have this really kind of after he's died, I found that to be really something that's the ability to sort of, I don't know if you, I don't know if you said you apologize, but you had a kind of almost a conversation with your dad. Yeah. Yeah, it was a kind of, it was an apology. It was a very combative relationship, not without humor, but combative. And I sort of, I was born with my fists up. So that's why you understand this word surrender is not, does not come natural to me. And yeah, and I, I, I, I, after a while, I did realize that maybe I had,
所以这本书给了我很多，我会这么说。所以谢谢你。你在书中再次谈到了你和你父亲的关系，关于你在教堂里的那一刻，以及你，在你父亲去世后，我发现那真的很特别，那种能够，我不知道你是否，我不知道你是否说你道歉了，但你和你父亲进行了一次几乎是对话的交流。是的，是的，这是一种道歉。那是一种非常对抗性的关系，并非没有幽默感，但具有对抗性。我有点，我出生时就握着拳头。所以这就是为什么你理解“投降”这个词，对我来说并不自然。是的，我，我，我，过了一会儿，我确实意识到也许我，
I wasn't there for him when he was going through so much. He'd lost my mother. There was three Irish males kind of screaming at each other in the house. And one of them is very precocious and, you know, annoying one. That would be me. And, and I would, you know, I was probably torturing him. And, and I, after he passed away, I did have a moment where I went up and I, I, I like going to church is actually better when there's no service on a moment. And especially in the language, I don't understand. Because then I get to feel the things without having to parse them, you know, intellectually. And I was just as an empty chapel. And yeah, I, I apologize to my father. And my theology doesn't allow me the belief that he was listening, but I was listening to myself.
当他经历那么多事情时，我没有在他身边。他失去了我的母亲。屋里有三个爱尔兰男性在互相尖叫。其中一个是早熟的，你知道，烦人的一个。那会是我。而且，我，你知道，我可能在折磨他。而且，我，在他去世后，我确实有一个时刻，我走上去，我，我喜欢去教堂，其实当没有礼拜的时候更好。特别是在我不懂的语言里。因为那样我就能感受到那些东西，而不必在智力上解析它们，你知道。我只是在一个空荡荡的教堂里。是的，我，我向我父亲道歉了。我的神学不允许我相信他在听，但我是在听我自己。
And there's a romantic part of me does believe he was listening. And, and something did change in me. And I, yeah, I think my voice changed. I walked different after you confess things. People, you know, they say this coming out of the confession box. That's for Irish Catholics. But, you know, the Jews have your therapists. We have the priests. But people emerge from these sessions different, walk different. They, you know, so much lighter. And, and yeah, my, my voice changed a bit around that time. And my father was a tenor. Jason, anything you want to get off your chest right now, go ahead. Bono's here. And all their Bono is here. Yeah. Well, but I talk a little bit more about, about that, about that, that process of going
我内心浪漫的一部分确实相信他在听。而且，我身上确实发生了一些变化。而且，我，是的，我想我的声音变了。忏悔之后，我走路的方式都不一样了。人们，你知道，他们说从忏悔室出来。那是给爱尔兰天主教徒的。但是，你知道，犹太人有你们的治疗师。我们有牧师。但人们从这些会议中出来后会变得不同，走路方式也不同。他们，你知道，轻盈多了。而且，是的，我的，我的声音在那段时间变了一些。我父亲是一位男高音。杰森，有什么你想现在倾诉的吗，尽管说。波诺在这里。所有的波诺都在这里。是的。嗯，但再多谈一点，关于那个过程，关于
through the memories and then writing those down in a, in a, in a literal, accurate sense. In comparison to the way I would imagine you've been doing it for years and years as a songwriter, talking about yourself, your feelings, your thoughts on things, your, your, your perspective on the world in much more of a metaphorical way, in a poetic way, in a rhyming way. Did you, did you find yourself going through the same themes and issues and, and getting more from it in that sort of catharsis exercise by writing in literal terms as opposed to metaphor? That's very actorly of you. And I appreciate that question. Catharsis is exactly right word. But it's very different, you know, writing a book, my own book, what I wrote myself, you know, it's different
经历记忆，然后以一种字面、准确的方式写下来。与我想象中你多年来作为词曲作者所做的方式相比，谈论你自己、你的感受、你对事物的想法、你对世界的看法，以一种更隐喻的方式，以一种诗意的方式，以一种押韵的方式。你，你是否发现自己经历了相同的主题和问题，并通过这种宣泄练习，以字面术语而不是隐喻来写作，从中得到了更多？你很有演员范儿。我很欣赏那个问题。宣泄是完全正确的词。但这非常不同，你知道，写一本书，我自己的书，我自己写的，你知道，它不同
to writing songs with songs. I tend to find sort of landscapes, emotional landscapes, feelings. I want to, I want to kind of enter into it. They're very abstract, oblique, often. And then I'll find a concrete situation, as you referred to Will in your very kind introduction, you know, I will use a real life situation. But songwriting, for me, is primarily investigation inquiry into the emotions around an issue. Here with the book, and remember, it's really far-fetched already to write, you know, it's sort of beyond navelgazing. You know, why would you foist your memoir, I call it a memoir, when it should really be a we-moire, because I mean, I mean, loads of bands, actually. But there was, there is, I think, okay to share these thoughts, because they might
于写歌。写歌时，我倾向于寻找某种景观，情感景观，感受。我想，我想进入其中。它们非常抽象、晦涩，通常如此。然后我会找到一个具体的场景，正如你提到的，威尔，在你非常友好的介绍中，你知道，我会使用一个现实生活中的场景。但写歌，对我来说，主要是对围绕一个问题的各种情绪的调查和探究。在这里，书里，记住，写这个已经很牵强了，你知道，这有点超出了自我沉思。你知道，为什么要强加你的回忆录，我称之为回忆录，当它实际上应该是一部“我们回忆录”时，因为我是说，我是说，很多乐队，其实。但有，我认为，分享这些想法是可以的，因为它们可能
be useful to other people. And at the very least, they might explain what I've been doing with my life to my family and friends, you know. But it was different. You know, I love that you said, you apologized to your father, because my father just apologized to me about leaving early and leaving us with not, he didn't, he didn't apologize. No, I was going to say, wait, what? But I did, but Bono, I did one of those ancestry shows where they trace your ancestry, and all of my relatives are from Dingle and County Kerry. And we, my grandfather, my dad's I, my grandfather, my great-grandfather, my great-great-great-great-great-great-grandfather, they have all this information. And every single one of them, I'm not exaggerating,
对其他人有用。至少，它们可能会向我的家人和朋友解释我一生都在做什么，你知道。但这很不同。你知道，我很喜欢你说你向你父亲道歉，因为我父亲刚刚向我道歉，关于早早离开，没有给我们留下什么，他没有，他没有道歉。不，我正要说，等等，什么？但我确实，但波诺，我做了一个那种祖先节目，他们追踪你的祖先，我所有的亲戚都来自丁格尔和凯里郡。我们，我的祖父，我爸爸的，我的祖父，我的曾祖父，我的曾曾曾曾曾曾祖父，他们有所有这些信息。而且他们每一个人，我没有夸张，
every single one of them arrested for drunken behavior, beating people up. I visited the jail where they all went. It was an insane, insane ancestry of craziness. Sean, I'm here to, I'm here to absolve you of that guilt, because those were days where the British were responsible for incarceration. And they were, we call those people rebels, okay? Okay. And that's why they were being put away. And, and yes, these are, these are slurs on their reputation. And have you asked yourself the question, Sean, just why do my relatives speak in a Jamaican accent? Or the other way around, have you ever gone, gosh, Bob Marley sounds a lot like he's from Dingle, like my grandparents. One, two, three, the whole thing gonna be all right.
他们每一个人都因为醉酒行为、殴打他人而被捕。我参观了他们都被关过的监狱。那是一个疯狂的、疯狂的疯狂祖先。肖恩，我在这里，我在这里免除你的那种内疚，因为那是英国人负责监禁的日子。他们是，我们称那些人为叛军，好吗？好吗？这就是为什么他们被关起来的原因。而且，是的，这些是对他们名誉的诽谤。你有没有问过自己这个问题，肖恩，为什么我的亲戚说话带着牙买加口音？或者反过来，你有没有想过，天哪，鲍勃·马利听起来很像来自丁格尔，像我的祖父母。一，二，三，一切都会好起来的。
Right. Oh, yeah. Because, yeah, that very sing song can be, I can explain it if you want, but you don't have to. I mean, this is... Well, wait, no, no, I do want you to explain it because you do very famously, I've watched it a dozen times over the years, your introduction of Bob Marley into the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame. And it's, oh, many times, man, I love it. It's one of the great speeches. I always find speeches like that to be my favorite kind of like induction speeches, things like that, when people really think about it. I don't know, there's something about it that kind of, and, and that is one of the great ones. And you talk about the similarities. Why is an Irishman inducting a Jamaican? And what are the similarities? And the audience kind of laughs,
对。哦，是的。因为，是的，那种非常朗朗上口的歌声，如果需要我可以解释，但你不必。我是说，这是……嗯，等等，不，不，我确实想让你解释，因为你非常出名，我多年来看过十几次，你将鲍勃·马利引入摇滚名人堂的介绍。而且，哦，很多次，伙计，我喜欢它。这是最伟大的演讲之一。我总是发现那样的演讲是我最喜欢的，像那样的入选演讲，当人们真正思考它的时候。我不知道，它有一种东西，那种，而且，那确实是伟大的演讲之一。你谈到了相似之处。为什么一个爱尔兰人要引入一个牙买加人？有什么相似之处？观众有点笑了，
he says, bear with me. Yeah. But then you, and one of the things you talk about, the British, you're like, yeah, everything, all clear now. The green, the herb, you mentioned that a bunch of times. And you talk about when the jackboots of colonialism retreat, what it means to, not just to get up, but to stay standing up. There's so many great themes. Oh, that's great. It kept it in the, in the Bob Marley Museum in Kingston. And he's from Irish town, of course. And, and it turns out there were some indentured people, forcefully taken to Irish people, taken to the Caribbean. It's not the same thing as slavery is, or anything like it, but it was rough. And there were, at the time of James I and Cromwell,
他说，请耐心听我说。是的。但随后你，你谈到的事情之一，英国人，你说，是的，现在一切都清楚了。绿色，草药，你提到了好几次。你谈到当殖民主义的铁靴撤退时，这意味着什么，不仅仅是站起来，而是保持站立。有这么多伟大的主题。哦，那太棒了。它被保存在金斯顿的鲍勃·马利博物馆里。他当然来自爱尔兰镇。而且，事实证明，有一些契约劳工，被强行带走的爱尔兰人，被带到了加勒比海。这和奴隶制不一样，或者任何类似的东西，但它很艰难。而且在詹姆斯一世和克伦威尔时期，
up to, I think, I mean, it's disputed, but 3000 to 40,000 from Dingle and from Kerry, honestly, I'm not joking this. I'm not smoking duet at this point. And it is, you know, it's interesting. But I think we are spiritually also quite close to that, that kind of the Bob Marley way of the world where he could sing of his faith, for example, when you two dropped our second album, and we missed the bit about singing songs about girls before we got on to God, like Van Morrison. And we started off, like, with God. And our manager was going, this is not going to go well. And Chris Blackwell, who, you know, discovered Bob Marley and founded Island Records that we were assigned to, he was like, Oh, no, you know, no, this is, this is all part of it,
直到，我想，我是说，这有争议，但有3000到4000人来自丁格尔和凯里，老实说，我不是在开玩笑。我此时此刻没有抽烟。而且，你知道，这很有趣。但我认为我们在精神上也相当接近那种鲍勃·马利的处世方式，他可以歌唱他的信仰，例如，当U2发行我们的第二张专辑时，我们错过了在接触上帝之前唱关于女孩的歌的部分，就像范·莫里森那样。我们一开始，就像，和上帝一起。我们的经理说，这不会有好结果。而克里斯·布莱克威尔，你知道，发现了鲍勃·马利并创立了我们签约的Island唱片公司，他说，哦，不，你知道，不，这是，这是它的一部分，
you know, the whole world. And, and, and, and sort of Irish people and Jamaicans, I think, we're in, I like to think at our best, we're, we have this kind of, we work body, spirit, and so that's quite a pretentious thing for your smart list podcast. But I believe our listeners are nothing but if not pretentious. And we will be right back. Smart list is sponsored by better help. You know, I feel best about myself when I feel loved, but the only way to feel loved really is if you love yourself. So how do you get to love yourself and not feel like, you know, this feels gross, like it feels like selfish, it feels like icky, like love yourself. That's those dumb cliches and weird. Well, it's all about like self care. And
你知道，整个世界。而且，而且，而且，爱尔兰人和牙买加人，我认为，我们处于，我喜欢认为在我们最好的时候，我们，我们有这种，我们工作身体、精神，所以这对你们的SmartList播客来说是一件相当自命不凡的事情。但我相信我们的听众除了自命不凡什么都不是。我们马上回来。SmartList由BetterHelp赞助。你知道，当我感到被爱时，我对自己感觉最好，但真正感到被爱的唯一方式是你爱你自己。那么你如何做到爱自己而不觉得，你知道，这感觉很恶心，感觉很自私，感觉很黏糊，像爱你自己。那些愚蠢的陈词滥调和奇怪的东西。嗯，这都是关于自我保健。而且
part of that self care is self mental health care. And so I try to really focus on that a lot, because if I can't be my best self and be focused and, and love myself, then nobody else can and I can't be there for anybody else. And part of what gets me there is therapy, right? Because when you're at your best, you can do great things. For me, working with a therapist can help you get closer to the best version of you, because when you feel empowered, you're more prepared to take on everything life throws at you. If you're thinking of giving therapy a try, better help is a great option. It's convenient, flexible, affordable, and entirely online. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists anytime for
这种自我保健的一部分是自我心理健康保健。所以我试着真正专注于这一点，因为如果我不能成为最好的自己，不能专注，不能爱自己，那么别人也无法爱我，我也无法为任何人服务。让我达到这一点的部分原因是治疗，对吧？因为当你处于最佳状态时，你可以做伟大的事情。对我来说，与治疗师合作可以帮助你更接近最好的自己，因为当你感到被赋能时，你更有准备去应对生活抛给你的一切。如果你正在考虑尝试治疗，BetterHelp是一个很好的选择。它方便、灵活、实惠，而且完全在线。只需填写一份简短的问卷，即可与持证治疗师匹配，并随时更换治疗师，无需
no additional charge. If you want to live a more empowered life, therapy can get you there. Visit betterhelp.com slash smartlist today to get 10% off your first month. That's better help hglp.com slash smartlist. We get support from FanDuel. NFL wildcard weekend is here. And the easiest way to get into the playoffs is with FanDuel, America's number one sports book. New customers joined today to get started with $150 and free bets guaranteed when you place your first $5 bet. Just sign up with promo code smartlist. FanDuel has all your favorite bets from the money line to point spreads to player props. Plus, you can even combine your bets for a chance at a bigger play out with the same game parlay. You know what I was thinking about?
额外费用。如果你想过上更有力量的生活，治疗可以带你到达那里。今天就访问betterhelp.com/smartlist，获得首月10%的折扣。那是betterhelp.com/smartlist。我们得到了FanDuel的支持。NFL外卡周末到了。进入季后赛最简单的方法就是通过美国第一体育博彩公司FanDuel。新客户今天加入，在您进行首次5美元投注时，即可获得150美元的免费投注保证。只需使用促销代码smartlist注册。FanDuel拥有您所有喜欢的投注，从胜负盘到让分盘再到球员道具。此外，您甚至可以通过同场连赢组合投注，获得更大回报的机会。你知道我在想什么吗？
Have you ever played banana grams? It's a tile game. It's like Scrabble, but there's no board. You just put the tiles on the thing. And Scotty and I always play banana grams. And I wish they had a FanDuel for banana grams, because you know what? I'd win all the time. I think I'd win all the time. He's an excellent speller, but I'm faster with tiles. You may have read that about me. I can like do like a bathroom, like subway tile faster than anybody. But when I'm playing with tiles, like with letter tiles, I'm just, I'm faster. But anyway, I wish they had a FanDuel for banana grams. That'd be kind of amazing. All on an app that's safe, secure and easy to use. So football fans, don't miss out, place your first $5 bet to get $150 and free bets, win or lose
你玩过Banana Grams吗？这是一种瓷砖游戏。它像拼字游戏，但没有棋盘。你只是把瓷砖放在东西上。我和斯科蒂总是玩Banana Grams。我希望他们有Banana Grams的FanDuel，因为你知道吗？我会一直赢。我想我会一直赢。他是一个出色的拼写者，但我用瓷砖更快。你可能读到过关于我的那件事。我可以像浴室一样，像地铁瓷砖一样比任何人都快。但当我玩瓷砖时，比如字母瓷砖，我只是，我更快。但不管怎样，我希望他们有Banana Grams的FanDuel。那会很棒。所有这些都在一个安全、可靠且易于使用的应用程序上。所以足球迷们，不要错过，进行您的首次5美元投注，即可获得150美元的免费投注，无论输赢
with promo code smartless. Make every moment more with FanDuel official sportsbook partner of the NFL. 21 plus exclusions apply. See show notes for full disclaimer. And now back to the show. Bono, I wanted to ask you about speaking great concerts. One of the all time great live records with you guys at Red Rocks, you two. And there's that great beginning of a Sunday Bloody Sunday. When you start and you say, there's been a lot of talk about this next song, maybe, maybe too much talk. This song is not a rebel song. By the way, I'm not reading it. I've got to memorize since it came out. This song is Sunday Bloody Sunday. The number of times I've uttered those words and not known what they meant and didn't know what they
使用促销代码smartless。让每一刻都与NFL官方体育博彩合作伙伴FanDuel更精彩。21岁以上，适用排除条款。查看节目说明以获取完整免责声明。现在回到节目。波诺，我想问你关于伟大的音乐会。你们在红岩（Red Rocks）的U2现场录音是有史以来最伟大的现场唱片之一。在《Sunday Bloody Sunday》的开头有那段伟大的开始。当你开始时，你说，关于下一首歌有很多讨论，也许，也许讨论得太多了。这首歌不是一首反叛歌曲。顺便说一句，我没在读它。自从它出来后我就背下来了。这首歌是《Sunday Bloody Sunday》。我念出这些词的次数，却不知道它们意味着什么，也不知道它们
meant at the time when you said them. And it was almost impromptu or was impromptu. If you could maybe tell us a little bit about that introduction to Sunday Bloody Sunday was this with these old hangovers on us, you know, after a Saturday night. I, this song is a very powerful song. I think of it strangely as like a Marley song. Always think about it a little bit like that. And while Edge was working on it in Dublin, I was working on it in Jamaica funnily enough on my honeymoon having to try and explain to my missus why our honeymoon album is going to be called War. But yeah, it's a powerful song. And, but it, it kind of got us into some trouble and where people thought we were taking sides in, you know, in a country which was almost
在你说出它们时意味着什么。这几乎是即兴的，或者就是即兴的。如果你能也许告诉我们一点关于《Sunday Bloody Sunday》的那个介绍，这是带着这些旧宿醉，你知道，在周六晚上之后吗？我，这首歌是一首非常有力量的歌。我奇怪地认为它就像一首马利（Marley）的歌。总是有点那样想。当Edge在都柏林创作它时，我正在牙买加，有趣的是，在我的蜜月期间，不得不试着向我的太太解释为什么我们的蜜月专辑要叫《War》。但是的，这是一首有力量的歌。而且，它，它有点让我们陷入了一些麻烦，人们认为我们在选边站，你知道，在一个几乎
at civil war on sectarian lines. And, you know, there's only, we say this, there's one and a half Catholics in YouTube. So you've got Larry, Mullen, and I consider myself, because my father was Catholic, half Catholic, but I was raised in the Church of Ireland. And then you have the two Brits in the band, Adam and Edge. So they came in from the UK. So we were like a social experiment you two at the time. And, and we didn't want to get caught up in this Sunday by Sunday rah, rah, rah, let's raise some money for the paramilitaries to go and hurt people and, and worse, you know, you know, extinguish lives with these guns that were bought. And, you know, in all across America, people, you know, were tin-copping and looking for money for the freedom fighters. And it wasn't
处于宗派内战的国家。而且，你知道，只有，我们这么说，U2里有一个半天主教徒。所以你有拉里·穆伦，而我把自己算作，因为我父亲是天主教徒，半个天主教徒，但我是在爱尔兰教会长大的。然后乐队里有两个英国人，亚当和Edge。所以他们是从英国来的。所以我们当时就像一个社会实验U2。而且，而且我们不想卷入这种《Sunday Bloody Sunday》的狂热中，去为准军事组织筹集资金去伤害人，而且，更糟的是，你知道，你知道，用这些买来的枪熄灭生命。而且，你知道，在整个美国，人们，你知道，在乞讨，为自由战士寻找资金。那不是
as simple as freedom fighting. And my father was a Catholic, but he was very suspicious of nationalism. And he used to say, he had this great line, he quote the playwright sing, he'd say, what is Ireland? But the land that keeps my feet from getting wet. And I'd like, that's a great quote. When I was writing a book, I discovered he made it up. Sing never said that. And it's a great quote, because it's just saying, just be careful about boundaries. And, you know, countries are just stories you tell yourself. And you want to be very careful about going to war with your next door neighbor. And so I used to introduce it. And it's, I'm sure it's, it's, it's annoying sound I make when I'm saying that, because I've, I suffered from a telephone voice on stage. Like, really,
就像自由斗争一样简单。我父亲是天主教徒，但他对民族主义非常怀疑。他过去常说，他有一句很棒的话，引用剧作家辛格的话，他说：“什么是爱尔兰？不过是让我双脚不被弄湿的那片土地。”我觉得这真是一句妙语。当我写书时，我发现那是他编的。辛格从未说过那句话。但这确实是一句妙语，因为它只是在说，要对界限保持警惕。而且，你知道，国家只是你自己告诉自己的故事。你得非常小心，不要和你的邻居开战。所以我过去常介绍它。而且，我肯定，我说话时发出的声音很烦人，因为我在舞台上患上了“电话嗓”。真的，
I don't know, I, it's a funny sound. It doesn't sound like me. Edge and I went to see a film called Killing Bono. He was going to enjoy it a little more than me. And the actor played, I said, he doesn't sound like me though, does he, Edge? And he said, no, he does. He sounds like the way you speak on stage or on the telly. And he's been doing his research on Google. That's a very good Bono, but it's your telephone voice Bono. And so when I hear, there's been a lot of talk about this song, I like, cool, you just, just turn it down a little bit. But, but that's me in the 80s. And, you know, I still feel as strong about it. I'm just, you know, I just, I hate to break it to you, man, but it's, it's iconic. So I'm, I'm sorry. I apologize for the world.
我不知道，这是一种奇怪的声音。听起来不像我。Edge和我去看了一部叫《杀死波诺》的电影。他比我更享受这部电影。我问扮演我的演员：“他听起来不像我，对吧，Edge？”他说：“不，他很像。他听起来就像你在舞台上或电视上说话的样子。”他一直在谷歌上做研究。那是一个非常好的波诺，但那是你的“电话嗓”波诺。所以当我听到关于这首歌的很多讨论时，我就想，酷，你只要，只要把它调小一点点。但那是我在80年代的样子。而且，你知道，我对此仍然感觉强烈。我只是，你知道，我不想让你失望，伙计，但它是标志性的。所以我，我很抱歉。我为这个世界道歉。
Wait, sidebar. Are you sitting on the floor? Yeah, he is. Yeah, man. Keeps it real down there. All right. Cause there's a couch. Thanks. Yeah. We sit on the floor. We eat our children. Sean, don't start a cute, you've got a TV behind you that you've never turned on. So, by the way, that is so true. He puts on the yule log on that thing. Hey, Bono, talk to, talk to us about your, you know, your music is always so passionate and authentic. Always feels like you're, you're writing and you're singing from the heart. And that takes, that takes a lot of, a lot of passion to be that, that genuine. Have you found that the older you've gotten, the smarter you've gotten, the more spiritual intelligence,
等等，插一句。你坐在地板上吗？是的，他确实在坐。是的，伙计。在那儿保持真实。好吧。因为这儿有沙发。谢谢。是的。我们坐在地板上。我们吃掉我们的孩子。肖恩，别开始装可爱了，你身后有一台你从没打开过的电视。顺便说一句，那太真实了。他会在那东西上放壁炉里的原木。嘿，波诺，跟我们谈谈你的，你知道，你的音乐总是那么充满激情和真实。总是感觉你是在用心写作和歌唱。要做到那么真诚，需要，需要很多很多的激情。你有没有发现，随着年龄的增长，你变得更聪明了，有了更多的精神智慧，
um, informational intelligence, um, emotional intelligence, that the passion for things that don't make sense for you, like maybe when you were younger, that now do make sense for you, does the passion go, go down and make it harder to write and sing more passionately because you simply have more things figured out and that you're just, or you're easier with things or you're not pushing back against things. You're letting, you know, I just find that as I get older, I'm just like, uh, I'm not going to sweat the small shit as much anymore. And it's just sort of a maturation. By the way, for Jason, like passion and soul, it's all like a math equation. Go ahead, Bono. I'm not sure, I'm not sure my IQ is high enough to actually understand that question.
嗯，信息智慧，嗯，情感智慧，对于那些对你来说没有意义的事情，比如当你年轻的时候，现在对你来说却有意义了，激情是否会减退，让你更难写出和唱出更激情的作品，因为你只是，你知道，你只是把事情想通了，或者你对事情更随和了，或者你不再抵触事情了。你让，你知道，我只是发现随着年龄增长，我只是觉得，呃，我不再那么纠结于琐事了。这只是一种成熟。顺便说一句，对于杰森来说，激情和灵魂就像一个数学方程式。继续吧，波诺。我不确定，我不确定我的智商是否高到足以真正理解那个问题。
But I, my EQ can figure it out. Um, uh, you know, yeah, I was, it's, oh my God, I think it was Seinfeld who said, you know, he's no, when he got to six, he had no problem, you know, just turning people down. He goes, nah, can't do that. Yeah. And he said, when he gets to 70, he just won't reply. And I have, yeah, I've, I've, I'm, who's the guy in the villain on James Bond? Dr. No. I'm Dr. Yes. And I try to solve problems for people I shouldn't be necessarily in my activism. I do tend to help God across the road, like she's a little old lady. Come on, God. I know exactly what's to do here. Um, I, I am actually part of the process of writing the book is just actually just trying to be in the moment. I'm in more and, and just, and, and listening.
但我，我的情商能弄明白。嗯，呃，你知道，是的，我当时，哦天哪，我想是宋飞说的，你知道，他没有，当他到了60岁，他拒绝别人时没有任何问题，你知道，他说，不，做不到。是的。他说当他到了70岁，他干脆就不回复了。而我，是的，我，我是，詹姆斯·邦德里的那个反派是谁？诺博士。我是“是的博士”。我倾向于在我的行动主义中为那些我不一定应该参与的人解决问题。我确实倾向于帮助上帝过马路，就像她是一位老太太一样。来吧，上帝。我知道这里该怎么做。嗯，我，我实际上是写书过程的一部分，只是试图活在当下。我更多地在，而且，而且只是，而且，而且在倾听。
I'm really, does this Franciscan friar called Richard Rohr, who I just, he's just a genius. He's just a, he's amazing. And, uh, I read him, he's got a place called the center of action and contemplation out there in Albuquerque, the center of the action. And I like that order. Um, but I might need to reverse it for the, you know, I might need to do some more contemplating before I act. And, and I'm getting to that. Yeah. You can't, you, how many more blows have you got and to throw and this sort of pushing shoulder against the door. I mean, I was used to it, you know, politically, whether it was, you know, people who didn't want to see me or didn't want to meet the activists that I represent fighting for universal access to, to AIDS drugs or whatever,
我真的，有位叫理查德·罗尔的方济各会修士，我只是，他简直是个天才。他简直，他太棒了。而且，呃，我读过他的书，他在阿尔伯克基有个地方叫行动与沉思中心，行动的中心。我喜欢那个顺序。嗯，但我可能需要为，你知道，我可能需要在行动前多做些沉思。而且，而且我正在达到那个阶段。是的。你不能，你，你还有多少拳头可以挥舞，这种推着肩膀抵住门的感觉。我的意思是，我习惯了，你知道，在政治上，无论是，你知道，那些不想见我的人，或者不想见我所代表的那些为争取艾滋病药物普及而奋斗的活动家，或者其他什么，
I would, I'd be ready to put my shoulders to the door, break it down, you know, but now I'm sort of thinking, maybe, maybe there's a key in the lock. Maybe, maybe just turn it and, you know, stop fighting. I think Sean, by the way, didn't in college you say that there were a lot of blows in the center for action, which is what you guys called behind the, behind the soda machine. Yeah. Sorry. Williams? Does your father call you William? Yeah, he does. My mother called me William. Be quiet. But I do want to, you know, one of the things, Bono, before I read your book or read parts of your book and read all this stuff about what you've been doing. And I had seen years ago, I don't know if you're aware of it, but frontline did a two-part piece, a documentary
我，我会准备好用肩膀抵住门，把它撞开，你知道，但现在我有点在想，也许，也许锁里有把钥匙。也许，也许只要转动它，你知道，停止战斗。我想肖恩，顺便说一句，你在大学时不是说行动中心里有很多拳头吗，也就是你们在汽水机后面叫的地方。是的。抱歉。威廉姆斯？你父亲叫你威廉吗？是的，他叫。我母亲叫我威廉。安静。但我确实想，你知道，其中一件事，波诺，在我读你的书或读你书的部分内容并读了所有关于你所做的事情之前。几年前我见过，我不知道你是否知道，但《前线》做了一个两部分的专题，一部纪录片
series on the age of AIDS. And I thought at the time, I remember thinking like, we've all read everything about AIDS. I mean, how much more can there be? And it was absolutely illuminating. It's like 2006, I think. And a big part of it was they focused a lot on what you did in terms of not just raising money. And this always struck me. And I've talked about it a lot over the years to various people. Anybody will listen. At a time when, especially this country needed to really step up and help combat AIDS in Africa, you came over here and you reached across lines, and you ended up in a meeting with, I know you first met with Paul O'Neill, and then you went over to Africa and did amazing things and illuminated him. He was then secretary of the
关于艾滋病时代的系列片。当时我想，我记得当时想，我们都读过关于艾滋病的一切。我的意思是，还能有多少呢？但这绝对是启发性的。我想那是2006年左右。很大一部分是他们重点关注了你在不仅仅是筹款方面所做的事情。这总是让我印象深刻。多年来我曾多次与不同的人谈论过这一点。任何愿意听的人。在一个时期，特别是这个国家需要真正站出来帮助抗击非洲的艾滋病时，你来到这里，跨越了界限，最终与保罗·奥尼尔会面，我知道你先是与他会面，然后你去了非洲并做了了不起的事情，启发了他。他当时是财政部部长。
Treasury. But then you also, you reached across and you appealed to Jesse Helms. And in effect, you said, you're a Christian. I'm a Christian. And I know that you've publicly stated that you, that, you know, that AIDS is a result of an immoral or life or whatever it was that he said. And you said, but we have an obligation because this is what God would do. And you spoke to him and your faith really drove you in that. And you got him to completely change his position. And that led to the biggest ever amount of money and really just sparked the U.S. getting involved in giving money to AIDS, which continues to this day. Amazing. Yeah. If you're an American, you're an AIDS activist, and that's amazing. I tell
但后来你也，你跨越了界限，向杰西·赫尔姆斯呼吁。实际上，你说，你是个基督徒。我是一个基督徒。我知道你公开声明过你，你知道，艾滋病是不道德生活的结果，或者无论他说了什么。你说，但我们有义务，因为这就是上帝会做的。你和他谈话，你的信仰确实驱动了你。你让他彻底改变了他的立场。这导致了有史以来最大的一笔资金，并真正引发了美国参与向艾滋病提供资金，这种情况一直持续到今天。太棒了。是的。如果你是美国人，你就是艾滋病活动家，那太棒了。我告诉
some people that they go, I don't want to be one. That's the largest health intervention in the history of medicine to fight a single disease up until this recent pandemic. And it's, and it was, you know, Bush and people, conservatives got involved. It started with Nancy Pelosi, actually. Her first speech on the floor of the Congress as she arrived to the Capitol was about AIDS. So many other people worked for this. And some of the better meetings I had were actually with, you know, staffers and policy wonks. And, you know, we used to meet on Friday nights. I'd find out which pubs they were going to. And I would, you know, meet the people. I'd meet, you know, that's the way to do it. It's not all principled or principled, as it was, you know. But then,
有些人，他们说，我不想成为那样的人。那是医学史上抗击单一疾病的最大规模的健康干预措施，直到最近这次大流行。而且，它是，你知道，布什和一些人，保守派参与了进来。其实是从南希·佩洛西开始的。她到达国会山后在国会大厅发表的第一次演讲就是关于艾滋病的。还有很多人为此工作。我进行的一些更好的会议实际上是与，你知道，工作人员和政策专家。而且，你知道，我们过去常在周五晚上见面。我会找出他们要去哪些酒吧。我会，你知道，去见那些人。我会见，你知道，那是做事的方法。这并不全是原则性的，或者像它那样原则性的。但后来，
you know, yeah, Jesse had this thing and he, Jesse Helms, a cold warrior, but he repented on the steps of the Senate for the way he talked about HIV AIDS. And he actually, and I used, of course, the scriptures, which, which I, you know, as a writer, you know, whether it's Bob Dylan, or it's Nick Cave, or it's, you know, it's all my Leonard Cohen. They know my favorite writers, all versed in the scriptures. And, you know, and I went after them because I, my attitude was so, so who would Jesus be hanging out with here, you know? And, and what's, you know, where's the judgmental part of Jesus? Jesus didn't speak in judgment about anybody. In fact, the only thing Jesus spoke in judgment about was the way we treat the poor. And he was, you know, stopped in his
你知道，是的，杰西有这个想法，他，杰西·赫尔姆斯，一个冷战战士，但在参议院台阶上为他谈论艾滋病毒/艾滋病的方式忏悔了。他实际上，而且我过去，当然，使用了经文，这，这我，你知道，作为一个作家，你知道，无论是鲍勃·迪伦，还是尼克·凯夫，还是，你知道，都是我的莱昂纳德·科恩。他们知道我最喜欢的作家，都精通经文。而且，你知道，我去找他们，因为我，我的态度是，那么，耶稣会和谁在一起呢，你知道？而且，你知道，耶稣的评判部分在哪里？耶稣没有评判任何人。事实上，耶稣唯一评判的事情就是我们对待穷人的方式。而且他，你知道，被他的
tracks. And, and I said, that's, you know, Jesus wasn't maybe, people think that Jesus is like focused on your pants. What's going on in your pants? You know, what, I mean, what vision of God do we have? And it's like, it's, it's, it's like we put ourself or, you know, our, you know, bad relative in the place of God. And of course, God is huge and gigantic love. And, and it's just so obvious. You don't even have to win the argument. Also, also known as common sense, God. Yes. Yeah, I like to think so. And anyway, these, these, these drugs are transformative. And I was just lucky to be part of it. And reaching out though, across the aisle, that was, that's a hard thing to do in America today. It's getting harder and harder. It's gotten harder. You'd think that
脚步拦住了。而且，我说，那是，你知道，耶稣可能不是，人们认为耶稣就像关注你的裤子。你的裤子里发生了什么？你知道，我的意思是，我们有什么样的上帝观？这就像，这就像我们把我们自己或者，你知道，我们的，你知道，糟糕的亲戚放在了上帝的位置上。当然，上帝是巨大而宏伟的爱。而且，这太明显了。你甚至不需要赢得争论。也被称为常识，上帝。是的。是的，我喜欢这么想。无论如何，这些，这些，这些药物是变革性的。我只是很幸运能参与其中。不过，跨越党派界限，在今天的美国这是一件很难做到的事情。这变得越来越难了。它变得更难了。你会认为
since then it would be, and, and, and again, if anything, a lot of sort of, you know, very right wing Christianity has been, you know, weaponized what they're saying in a way that doesn't seem that's sort of incongruous with the actual notion of Christianity. It's ridiculous. It is ridiculous. From your perspective over there, with fresh eyes of not being immersed in America, does, does it seem like there might be one obvious thing that you might recommend to us to focus on that, that would bring both sides together? Or can you come back, can you come back over and say this? Yeah, what, what would you, as you, you know, you put the commonality of, of, of faith with, with Jesse Helms and you, what would be the, the common thing that might, might bring both sides
从那时起它会是，而且，而且，而且如果有什么的话，很多，你知道，非常右翼的基督教已经，你知道，以一种似乎与基督教的实际概念不相容的方式武器化了他们所说的话。这太荒谬了。这确实很荒谬。从你在那边的角度来看，以没有沉浸在美国的新鲜眼光来看，是否似乎有一件显而易见的事情你可以建议我们关注，那将把双方团结在一起？或者你能回来，你能回来再说一遍吗？是的，你会，当你，你知道，你把信仰的共同点与，与杰西·赫尔姆斯和你，你会是什么，那个可能，可能把双方
together nowadays over here? I wonder. America doesn't exist yet. That's what I'm, that's, that's what I'm pitching at the moment. I, to conservatives and liberals, I say America is the greatest idea the world has ever had, but it doesn't exist yet. And for certain communities, it's not there. And the idea that you can write it, that you can create it now, people listening and the podcast thinking, well, what is America then? I, I, that is, it's on its way. And, and that's the, that's the most encouraging I could be. I agree about that. Is it an embracing of a coexistence? Sorry, Sean, is it, do you think, is the general sort of American idea, I wonder, just from, from your international perspective, is it, is it just a, to the extent that you are
团结在一起的共同点，如今在这里？我想知道。美国还不存在。这就是我，这就是我目前正在推销的。我，对保守派和自由派，我说美国是世界有史以来最伟大的想法，但它还不存在。对于某些社区来说，它不在那里。而且你可以写下它，你可以现在创造它的想法，人们听着播客心想，那么美国到底是什么？我，我，那是，它正在路上。而且，而且那是，那是，我能给出的最令人鼓舞的说法。我同意这一点。这是一种拥抱共存吗？抱歉，肖恩，是吗，你认为，一般的美国想法，我想知道，只是从，从你的国际视角来看，是吗，是吗，只是在某种程度上你
comfortable to coexist with other? Is that what the promise is? Yeah, that's exact. That's, that's a really good definition of it. And America is. Well, Jason just saw a bumper sticker. Yeah, it's a co-exist with him. Yeah, sorry. But, you know, it's, it's just, I, I mean, I love, as much as this book I've written is a, is a love letter to, you know, my Mrs. to Ali, it's also a love letter to America. And, and I, you know, came here. I mean, I, I, I went to city lights. I don't know if you've been to that bookstore in San Francisco, Ferlinghetti, Lawrence Ferlinghetti set it up. And I, I, I, I fell in love with America reading Ginsburg and Carowag and the plays of Sam Shepard and Patty Smith. I was like, wow, I was sort of, I didn't
舒服地与他人共存？这就是承诺吗？是的，那正是。那，那是一个非常好的定义。而且美国是。好吧，杰森刚刚看到了一个保险杠贴纸。是的，是与他共存。是的，抱歉。但是，你知道，这，这只是，我，我意思是，我爱，尽管我写的这本书是，是一封写给，你知道，我的夫人艾莉的情书，它也是一封写给美国的情书。而且，而且我，你知道，来到这里。我的意思是，我，我，我去了城市之光。我不知道你是否去过旧金山的那家书店，费林格蒂，劳伦斯·费林格蒂创办了它。而且我，我，我，我爱上了美国，读着金斯堡和凯鲁亚克，还有萨姆·谢泼德和帕蒂·史密斯的剧作。我当时想，哇，我当时有点，我没有
know I'd be getting to write about this America that I was reading about. But I, I even then just sensed this is, this is a mythological place as well as a physical landscape. And, and I, and I, there was two Americas really. And, and I wanted to write about both. It's amazing. You did, you, you wrote so much about it. I mean, Joshua Tree was really felt like you were flexing your American muscle. You were there. You guys were, you were absorbing and kind of reflecting back to us. You know, while I was Canadian, but close enough, you were sort of reflecting back to us what you were seeing. And you guys were kind of, you were out there at Joshua Tree and you were, had the hats and you had the thing and you were in the streets and you were doing the concert on the roof,
知道我会写关于我正在读的这个美国。但我，我即使在那时也感觉到这是，这是一个神话般的地方，也是一个物理景观。而且，而且我，而且我，确实有两个美国。而且，而且我想写关于这两个美国。太棒了。你做到了，你，你写了很多关于它的东西。我的意思是，约书亚树真的感觉就像你在展示你的美国肌肉。你在那里。你们在那里，你们在吸收并以某种方式向我们反映。你知道，虽然我是加拿大人，但足够接近了，你有点在向我们反映你所看到的。而且你们有点，你们在约书亚树那里，你们戴着帽子，你们有那个东西，你们在街上，你们在屋顶上做演唱会，
right? You did all that stuff in this kind of great way. And you, I don't know, there was all, there was all, there was, there was like a real absorption of American culture. And then, then you go on. The pop tour. What record was it? Yeah. What record did you assume the character of the flying? Acton Baby was the cutting down of the Joshua Tree. Cutting down of the Joshua Tree. Went to Berlin to record that. Yeah. Which is a great record. And I always wondered, there, there always felt like when you were kind of playing the persona of the rock star, it was very sort of Bowie-esque in a lot of ways. But like, did you, it was almost like, I thought, and I didn't, I'd never met you at that point, but I would often thought like,
对吧？你们以这种很棒的方式做了所有那些事情。而且你，我不知道，那里一直有，那里一直有，那里一直有，就像对美国文化的真正吸收。然后，然后你继续。流行巡演。是什么唱片？是的。什么唱片你扮演了飞行的角色？《注意宝贝》是砍掉约书亚树。砍掉约书亚树。去柏林录制那个。是的。那是一张很棒的唱片。而且我一直想知道，那里，那里一直感觉当你有点扮演摇滚明星的角色时，它在很多方面都非常像鲍伊。但是，你，这几乎就像，我想，而且我，我当时还没见过你，但我经常想，
I wonder if it was almost like a rejection of, because you had, you guys were so famous and you were so big. And it was almost like your way of dealing with fame in that way that it almost, who you, Bono, who was part of the world was this other entity that belonged to the world. And you were kind of stepping back and watching him as well. Was, was there any truth to that? Yeah, but I mean, yes, it was kind of, it was some kind of satire of, of fame and the rock star. But I'll be honest with you, you know what I mean? This was quite attractive. Yeah. And I was like, wow, I can get, I can, I can say shit. I would never say I can be this larger than life character. And I, you know, I was dressed head to toe in this kind of, you know, Elvis,
我想知道这是否几乎是一种拒绝，因为你，你们太出名了，你们太大了。这几乎就像你处理名声的方式，以至于它几乎，你，波诺，作为世界的一部分，是属于世界的另一个实体。而且你有点退后一步，也在看着他。这有什么真实性吗？是的，但我的意思是，是的，这是一种，这是一种对名声和摇滚明星的讽刺。但我会诚实地告诉你，你知道我的意思吗？这很有吸引力。是的。而且我当时想，哇，我可以得到，我可以，我可以胡说八道。我永远不会说我可以成为这个比生命更大的角色。而且我，你知道，我从头到脚穿着这种，你知道，猫王，
68 special meets Lurid meets Van, you know, Jim Morrison, the other Morrison. And I, I'm like, wow, I was an edge said, wow, you know, those plastic fans are starting to fit you a little too well there, dude. And, and, you know, I mean, I really, we, and in the nineties was so great to us because it, it unlocked us from being these, being just a collection of sounds and ideas. And I also needed just to chill out because, you know, just put the fist down for a while. And that's, you know, so you edge of myself have a place in the south of France for the last 30 years. That's where we met you. Well, I think first. And, and so, yeah, I needed to, I certainly needed to chill out and I got quite good at it. And then I felt in a way, you know, people say,
68特别版遇见Lurid遇见范，你知道，吉姆·莫里森，另一个莫里森。而且我，我当时想，哇，我当时Edge说，哇，你知道，那些塑料粉丝开始有点太适合你了，伙计。而且，而且，你知道，我的意思是，我真的，我们，而且在九十年代对我们太好了，因为它，它把我们从仅仅是一堆声音和想法的集合中解放了出来。而且我也需要冷静一下，因为，你知道，把拳头放下一会儿。而且那是，你知道，所以你Edge和我自己在法国南部有一个地方已经30年了。那就是我们遇见你的地方。好吧，我想首先。而且，所以，是的，我需要，我当然需要冷静下来，而且我做得相当不错。然后我以某种方式感觉到，你知道，人们说，
you know, oh yeah, then you went back to saving the world. The way I see it is I saved my own ass because I wanted to be useful again. I wanted to be useful to ins, these are corny words, but it's service. You know, I wanted, I needed to meet by the end of the nineties, I've done enough chilling. So I think I needed to be, I needed to, to get back to, to being useful. And that's when we did the drop the debt campaign and red and, and then one. And, but so they really did, it brought me on this other journey that I needed towards adulthood, but I haven't quite got there. But it was fun. But it was a big undertaking. And I know that you, you brought in, that's when you brought in our mutual friend, the great Tom
你知道，哦是的，然后你回去拯救世界了。我看到的拯救是我拯救了我自己的屁股，因为我想再次变得有用。我想对ins有用，这些是陈词滥调，但这是服务。你知道，我想，我需要到九十年代末，我已经冷静得够多了。所以我认为我需要，我需要，回到，变得有用。那就是我们做“放弃债务”运动和红色，然后是“一”。而且，但所以他们确实，它带我踏上了我需要的通往成年的另一段旅程，但我还没有完全到达那里。但这很有趣。但这是一项艰巨的任务。而且我知道你，你带进来了，那就是你带进我们共同的朋友，伟大的汤姆
Freston, who we've mentioned on the podcast before, the most interesting man in the world. They're the best life of anyone in the world, or anyone we know. Boy, if I was Tom Freston and Bono called my life the best life in the world, I'd feel pretty good. Congratulations, Tom. You got to get him on your podcast. He's a pirate company. Can't book him. Can't make a deal. Can I ask a question I've always wondered, which is where did, where did your name come from? Because I don't know your real name. I've only known you as Bono. Yeah. My oldest friend, Guggie, is a really extraordinary abstract painter of some renown around the world now, but it was street gang. And I've known him
弗雷斯顿，我们之前在播客中提到过，世界上最有趣的人。他们是世界上，或者我们认识的任何人中最好的生活。天哪，如果我是汤姆·弗雷斯顿，波诺称我的生活是世界上最好的生活，我会感觉很好。祝贺你，汤姆。你得让他上你的播客。他是一家海盗公司。预订不了他。做不了交易。我可以问一个我一直想知道的问题吗，那就是你的名字从哪里来？因为我不知道你的真名。我只知道你是波诺。是的。我最老的朋友，古吉，现在是世界各地颇有名望的非常杰出的抽象画家，但他当时是街头帮派。而且我认识他
since I was three. And he gave me the name Bono. And I can assure you he was not a Latin scholar. So Bono Vaz was the name of a hearing aid factory. It was not, he did not know it meant strong voice. There you go. Wow, that's fascinating. I didn't know that. I didn't know that. If you wanted to be of service in the 90s, you've got to see the clear need for that service 30 years later. Are you going to take a walk through our country again soon and give us some helpful talks and guidance and perspective? I don't think. I mean, I'm amazed that I've got away with it, to be honest with you. This is Irish Rockstar quoting the Declaration of Independence as the liner notes to his favorite album, following America into the bathroom.
从我三岁起。他给了我波诺这个名字。而且我可以向你保证他不是拉丁学者。所以波诺·瓦兹是一家助听器工厂的名字。它不是，他不知道它意味着强有力的声音。给你。哇，那太迷人了。我不知道那个。我不知道那个。如果你想在90年代提供服务，你必须看到30年后对该服务的明确需求。你很快会再次走遍我们的国家，给我们一些有益的谈话、指导和观点吗？我不认为。我的意思是，老实说，我很惊讶我能逃脱惩罚。这是一个爱尔兰摇滚明星引用《独立宣言》作为他最喜欢的专辑的内页说明，跟着美国进浴室。
Hey, it says this year, why are you doing that? And I'm like an annoying fan of America. And, you know, I'm thrilled that you let me in to your life, given me incredible life. But I'm, you know, I'm, yeah, it's, it's, there's, there's a lot to learn in this landscape for me. And I've not much much to teach other than one simple thing, which is, goes back to this Franciscan friar. Um, he says, listen, deep listening. That's what America needs to do. And not listening to the people that we don't agree with, maybe even listening to people we don't like. And, and people who annoy us. And if you can do that in your band, then the rest is, the rest will be easy. I really truly listen to people who annoy us. Sean, go ahead, say something.
嘿，它说今年，你为什么要那样做？而我就像一个烦人的美国粉丝。而且，你知道，我很高兴你让我进入你的生活，给了我不可思议的生活。但我，你知道，我，是的，它，它，它，在这个景观中有很多东西要学。而且我没什么可教的，除了一个简单的事情，那就是，回到这个方济各会修士。嗯，他说，听，深度倾听。这就是美国需要做的。而不是听我们不同意的人，也许甚至是听我们不喜欢的人。而且是那些惹恼我们的人。如果你能在你的乐队里做到这一点，那么剩下的，剩下的就会很容易。我真的真正听那些惹恼我们的人。肖恩，继续，说点什么。
Yeah, I truly do listen, I truly do listen to all new, as many news networks as I can to get all perspectives, even if I don't agree with them to your point. But also speaking of listening, the edge told me that you guys are going to go on tour in Vegas and he showed me the renderings of this new theater or something. It's going to be unbelievable. I mean, it's a brand new venue, right? That they're building just for you or are you the person? You are a news network now, because that's breaking news. And we haven't signed off on it. But if, if we do, if we do sign off on this, I will say that the, if we can pull off what we're talking about, it's not like anything we've ever done before. It's not like it's selling anything. Las Vegas
是的，我确实听，我确实听尽可能多的新闻网络以获得所有观点，即使我不同意他们的观点，正如你所说。但说到听，Edge告诉我你们要去拉斯维加斯巡演，他给我看了这个新剧院什么的渲染图。那将是不可思议的。我的意思是，这是一个全新的场地，对吧？他们专门为你建造的，还是你是那个人？你现在是一个新闻网络，因为那是突发新闻。而且我们还没有签署它。但如果，如果我们做，如果我们确实签署了这个，我会说，如果我们可以实现我们正在谈论的事情，它不像我们以前做过的任何事情。它不像是在卖任何东西。拉斯维加斯
has ever seen before. Have you seen some of the plans? Yes, it's, he showed me all the, it's incredible. If we pull, if this happens, it will be really extraordinary. And I, and again, I don't want to, I shouldn't be. Whatever it is, it sounds very exciting. Blame it on Edge. He showed, it's not me. No, no, I mean, he just showed me from my eyes only. But it's, it's incredible. It's great. You know, there's a lot, I'm interested in Las Vegas and for all kinds of reasons. And you kind of always have been, right? Yeah. Like I used to say, even going back to the fly and, and, and, and, you know, we used to say call it Las Vegas trash and, and Berlinish decadence. And I'm interested in the concept of faith versus look. I'm interested in, there's a great
以前见过。你看过一些计划了吗？是的，他给我看了所有的，它太不可思议了。如果我们拉，如果这发生了，那将是非常非凡的。而且，而且我，我不想，我不应该。无论它是什么，听起来都很令人兴奋。怪Edge吧。他展示了，不是我。不，不，我的意思是，他只是给我看，仅供我眼睛看。但它，它太不可思议了。太棒了。你知道，有很多，我对拉斯维加斯感兴趣，出于各种原因。而且你一直都是，对吧？是的。就像我过去常说的，甚至回到飞行和，和，和，你知道，我们过去常说称它为拉斯维加斯垃圾和，和柏林式的颓废。而且我对信仰与运气的概念感兴趣。我对，有一个伟大的
architectural manual called learning from Las Vegas about how don't knock it or laugh at it. This, this sort of fabulous architecture is not overtly male. It's not overtly, it's playful. And these cities that we live in are very male and big, you know, straight lines. We've lost curves, we've lost, and this, this, you know, Las Vegas in some ways looks like it's been designed by children. And I think that might be a good thing sometimes. Yeah. That's interesting. That's a good point. Another sidebar. I'm obsessed with your daughter and one of my favorite shows in the world called bad sister. She's good. She's incredible. And the show is amazing. And you must feel so proud of her. I mean, you can't stop talking about the show. It's one of the
建筑手册叫《向拉斯维加斯学习》，关于如何不要敲打它或嘲笑它。这种，这种美妙的建筑不是公开的男性化。它不是公开的，它是俏皮的。我们居住的这些城市非常男性化且巨大，你知道，直线。我们失去了曲线，我们失去了，而且这个，你知道，拉斯维加斯在某些方面看起来像是孩子们设计的。而且我认为这有时可能是一件好事。是的。那很有趣。那是一个很好的观点。另一个插曲。我痴迷于你的女儿和我世界上最喜欢的节目之一叫《坏姐妹》。她很好。她太不可思议了。而且节目太棒了。而且你一定为她感到骄傲。我的意思是，你不能停止谈论这个节目。它是其中之一
greatest. No, she's got a lot of, she's very, very funny. And she is a comedian and she, she can do what he wants, but she was playing these very sort of serious or tour chosen sort of muse parts. And then when she got this, she got to be more like herself, you know, a killer. Exactly. And then she's got a lot of discipline too. You strike me as somebody who would make a very, very good actor. And I feel like I may have seen you act in something. Don't insult the guy. I mean, what are you doing? No, no, no, but I, you know, look, it's beneath him. Sting is fantastic at it. Bowie was fantastic at it. Have you ever, do you have a yearning for that at all? Because I'd love to see it. I bet it would be fantastic.
最伟大的。不，她有很多，她非常，非常有趣。而且她是一位喜剧演员，而且她，她可以做他想做的事，但她过去常常扮演这些非常严肃的或巡回选择的缪斯角色。然后当她得到这个时，她变得更像她自己了，你知道，一个杀手。完全正确。而且她也有很多纪律。你给我的印象是一个会成为非常，非常好的演员的人。而且我觉得我可能见过你演什么东西。别侮辱那个人。我的意思是，你在做什么？不，不，不，但我，你知道，看，这对他来说太低了。斯汀在上面很棒。鲍伊在上面很棒。你有没有，你对此有任何渴望吗？因为我很想看到它。我敢打赌它会很棒。
Not really. I played myself in a film once, it was really hard. And, and I, I don't know, when I was younger, yes. Now, I'm, I don't know, and I'm starting to realize that the camera loves people who don't necessarily love the camera. I've spotted that. And I'd be more of a theater actor, you know. And I love being in the theater. And because that's where I get to break down the fourth wall. You can, I want to be in a theater where the actor could just feel like you can walk off the stage, just get into my life, get into my mind, follow me home, mug me on the way home. You know, you make out whatever, you know, it's, it's, that's the kind of thing I like. And it's harder to get off, it's harder to get off the silver screen, isn't it? And I would just, I think I look
不完全是。我曾经在一部电影里扮演我自己，那真的很难。而且，而且我，不知道，当我年轻的时候，是的。现在，我，不知道，而且我开始意识到相机喜欢那些不一定喜欢相机的人。我发现了这一点。而且我会更像一个戏剧演员，你知道。而且我喜欢在剧院里。因为那是我可以打破第四面墙的地方。你可以，我想在一个演员可以感觉就像你可以走下舞台，走进我的生活，走进我的思想，跟着我回家，在回家的路上抢劫我的剧院里。你知道，你随便怎么做，你知道，它，它，那是我喜欢的那种事情。而且更难离开，更难离开银幕，不是吗？而且我只是，我想我看起来
even more preposterous. You know, when you two went on Top of the Pops, our very first televised appearance on this legendary UK, you know, show the week's charts for music, we went on and our, our song went down the charts immediately because we looked so preposterous. And I, particularly, I looked like a sort of, I looked like somebody's given me an electric shock. And I'm doing the, I'm doing the sort of mad movements you do in a mirror, you know. And I think I'm seeing myself in a monitor or something. And so I look cross-eyed as well. And, and I don't think we've got an amazing audience in the UK. But, you know, I think there's some people I'm eating for them going, yeah, are you a crap then? I saw you on Top of the Pops. You were crap. But I'm
甚至更荒谬。你知道，当你们两个上《流行音乐排行榜》时，我们在英国这个传奇节目上的第一次电视亮相，你知道，每周的音乐排行榜，我们去了，我们的歌立即在排行榜上下滑，因为我们看起来太荒谬了。而且，特别是，我看起来像一个，我看起来像有人给了我电击。而且我正在做，我正在做你在镜子里做的那种疯狂动作，你知道。而且我想我在监视器里看到我自己什么的。所以我也看起来斗鸡眼。而且，而且我不认为我们在英国有很棒的观众。但是，你知道，我想有些人我正在为他们吃，说，是的，你是个垃圾吗？我在《流行音乐排行榜》上看到你了。你很垃圾。但我
just like, how old were you? I saw you on Top of the Pops make you a crap. And I'm like, crap. That was our, that was our second album. It was a song called Fire. Is that right? Yeah, it was crap. And, and I go, you know, that was, we got better. We got better. Yeah, right? Yeah. I just saw that one. That's, it's so, by the way, that's so Irish and so Canadians too. I have so many people I knew who I grew up with. And I go back and I go, saw that thing you did last year. Wasn't very good, was it? And I'm like, oh, thanks, man. Thanks. I thought Canadians were much more polite. No, they're not. No, no, no. They're really, they're really passive aggressive. To fellow Canadians, they show the real, the real devil. We're not like Scandinavian Scandinavian. If you're,
只是像，你多大了？我在《流行音乐排行榜》上看到你让你是个垃圾。而我像，垃圾。那是我们的，那是我们的第二张专辑。那是一首叫《火》的歌。是这样吗？是的，那是垃圾。而且，而且我去，你知道，那是，我们变好了。我们变好了。是的，对吧？是的。我刚看到那个。那，它太，顺便说一句，那太爱尔兰了，也太加拿大人了。我有这么多我认识的人，我一起长大。而且我回去，我说，看到你去年做的那件事了。不是很好，是吗？而我像，哦，谢谢，伙计。谢谢。我以为加拿大人更有礼貌。不，他们不是。不，不，不。他们真的很，他们真的很被动攻击。对同胞加拿大人，他们展示了真正的，真正的魔鬼。我们不像斯堪的纳维亚斯堪的纳维亚。如果你是，
you've been to Sweden a million times, I'm sure. And you go to Scandinavia, they go, they go, oh, look at you. You look quite fat. And you're like, Ben, what do you, nice to see you too. I'm just saying it too much fatter than last time I saw you. No, I got it. I got it. One more thing before you, I do want to mention, I know you mentioned your daughter and your son also, how, what's that experience been like? Your son Elijah's, he's got the band Inhaler who are doing really well, especially across Europe and the UK. They debuted at number one, I think. Wow. Yeah. The album went in at number one, which means they must have sold, you know, a thousand copies the way the things are going now. Are you so happy to have him off the payroll?
你已经去过瑞典一百万次了，我肯定。而且你去斯堪的纳维亚，他们去，他们去，哦，看看你。你看上去很胖。而你像，本，你，见到你也很高兴。我只是说它太胖了，比我上次见到你时。不，我明白了。我明白了。在你之前还有一件事，我确实想提一下，我知道你提到了你的女儿和你的儿子，那种经历是什么样的？你的儿子以利亚的，他有乐队Inhaler，他们做得很好，特别是在欧洲和英国。他们首发排名第一，我想。哇。是的。专辑进入时排名第一，这意味着他们一定卖了，你知道，一千份，按照现在事情的发展方式。你很高兴让他离开工资单吗？
Just at least. I think I'm going to be on his payroll. It's very annoying. It's very easy for, it's too easy for him. First of all, he looks like Elvis and he's like, you know, he's like, oh, he's in a high school band. They're ridiculously talented. And I'm saying, you know, the early gigs, you know, don't you, you know, are you, are you, there's some YouTube fans turning up and he goes, oh, don't mind the, the hairy ones. And then the other guy in the band goes, they're not even hairy now. They're bold. And I go, is this a problem for you? He says, dad, they buy the merch. And now, of course, they're selling out everywhere. And you know, and they're very sophisticated band. And, and he's effortless in so many ways. I didn't know he had those pipes.
至少。我想我会在他的工资单上。这很烦人。这对他来说太容易了。首先，他看起来像猫王，而且他像，你知道，他像，哦，他在高中乐队。他们非常有才华。而且我说，你知道，早期的演出，你知道，你不，你知道，你是，你是，有一些YouTube粉丝出现，他说，哦，别介意那些，那些毛茸茸的。然后乐队里的另一个人说，他们现在甚至不毛茸茸了。他们秃了。而我去，这对你是个问题吗？他说，爸爸，他们买周边。而现在，当然，他们到处售罄。而且你知道，而且他们是非常复杂的乐队。而且，而且他以很多方式毫不费力。我不知道他有那些管子。
I knew he could play guitar. He's got a great, he's got a great voice. And there are so many moments, of course, he's your son, where he sounds like, sounds like you. I wonder like, what is, so your wife, Allie, who's just amazing and, and you dedicate your book to her. And I've had the good fortune of meeting her a number of times. And what is it like for her? Do you, I wondered, like, is there part of her when your son started, you know, playing music, where she's like, great, now you've turned our son into a rock star as well? Like, you know what I mean? It was eerie for her, you know, because she was going to clubs, sometimes the same clubs. And when we were playing under beat 10 or 20 people there,
我知道他会弹吉他。他有很棒的，他有很棒的声音。而且有很多时刻，当然，他是你的儿子，他听起来像，听起来像你。我想知道，那么你的妻子，艾莉，她太棒了，而且，而且你把你的书献给她。而且我有幸见过她几次。而且这对她来说是什么样的？我好奇，就像，有没有她的一部分当你的儿子开始，你知道，演奏音乐时，她像，太好了，现在你也把我们的儿子变成了摇滚明星？就像，你知道我的意思吗？这对她来说很诡异，你知道，因为她去俱乐部，有时是同样的俱乐部。而且当我们演奏时，只有10或20人在那里，
and she's seeing her son. And yeah, I think that it was quite a thing. And, you know, she was like, you know, can you get him off the video games? He's on the video games all the time. And I remember a side lead up to me was like, I don't know, 14 or 15, I'm going, and he's, I don't know what it was, World of Warcraft or something. He's just looking and he's shooting things out of the sky, whatever they do. And I'm saying, how's it going? He goes, yeah, good. How's good? Yeah, you were getting really good at that. He goes, thanks. I said, you should practice that a bit more. He goes, what? I said, if you, if you really work on this, like, you could get like, you could be one of the best ever World of Warcraft ever. And he goes,
而且她看着她的儿子。而且是的，我认为那是一件相当大的事情。而且，你知道，她就像，你知道，你能让他离开电子游戏吗？他一直都在玩电子游戏。而且我记得一个侧面引导我，就像，14或15岁，我去，而且他，我不知道那是什么，魔兽世界什么的。他只是看着，他在从天上射东西，无论他们做什么。而且我说，怎么样？他说，是的，很好。怎么好？是的，你在这方面变得非常擅长。他说，谢谢。我说，你应该多练习一下。他说，什么？我说，如果你，如果你真的在这方面努力，就像，你可以得到，就像，你可以成为有史以来最好的魔兽世界之一。他说，
yeah, yeah, I said, yeah, when you're like 21, that's really gone. You're really gonna make a big impact on women with that. And he stopped. He looked at me. He goes, oh, yeah, right. I said, no, but you're an amazing guitar player. Just don't forget that. You're really, that's the only advice I gave him. And he's never even thought about any other advice I've tried to give him. That's so good. But I'll bet, I'll bet you gave, I bet you actually gave some very, very good, also crafty, parental, parental guidance there. You and your wife with him and your daughter, when they thought about doing something that might be kind of public facing, you know, growing up as, you know, your children, I'm sure there were, there were, there was a moment at least, where they were reluctant
是的，是的，我说，是的，当你21岁左右时，那真的没了。你真的会在这方面对女性产生很大的影响。而且他停了下来。他看着我。他说，哦，是的，对。我说，不，但你是一个了不起的吉他手。别忘了那个。你真的，那是我给他的唯一建议。而且他甚至从来没有想过我试图给他的任何其他建议。那太好了。但我敢打赌，我敢打赌你给了，我敢打赌你实际上给了非常，非常好的，也狡猾的，父母的，父母的指导。你和你的妻子和他以及你的女儿，当他们想到做一些可能有点公开面对的事情时，你知道，作为，你知道，你的孩子长大，我肯定有，有，有一个时刻至少，他们很勉强
to, you know, see if they could measure up. And I'll bet you and your wife gave some real good daddy, mommy stuff to encourage them. Irish people. Irish people were good to them. And because they were probably bored with their father, they really didn't bother these. And then we went to a local school, all our kids went to the local school and free school and, you know, progressive school and just a talk school project was called. And they were treated and mistreated like everybody else by their, by their mates. And, and they just grew up. It wasn't what would be harder for you, because I think fame might mean something different in America. I think it's a little harder to endure, because we always escape back to Dublin, to Ireland. And
去，你知道，看看他们是否能衡量。而且我敢打赌你和你的妻子给了真正好的爸爸，妈妈的东西来鼓励他们。爱尔兰人。爱尔兰人对他们很好。而且因为他们可能对他们的父亲感到厌烦，他们真的没有打扰这些。然后我们去了当地学校，我们所有的孩子都去了当地学校和免费学校，而且，你知道，进步学校和只是一个谈话学校项目叫。而且他们被他们的，他们的伙伴对待和虐待得像其他人一样。而且，而且他们只是长大了。那不会是对你来说更难的事情，因为我认为名声在美国可能意味着不同的东西。我认为这有点难忍受，因为我们总是逃回都柏林，回到爱尔兰。而且
sometimes I forget after, you know, say, after lockdown, I remember going out and going, oh, shit, I'm famed again. And I have to put on that stupid voice. I have to put on the funny walk. And no, the advice of their friends was as important as ours. And, and I don't think he's taught him much about his father's fame at all. I think he's just, he's just very focused on what he's doing with his band. Oh, that's great. That's great. Well, you guys, you guys have certainly cultivated a, like you said, you, your kids all go to the local, went to the local school. And, and I know that, you know, in the summertime, you and Ed spent a lot of time together and your family's kind of all, everybody together. And there's a real sense of that kind of community
有时我忘记了在，你知道，说，在封锁之后，我记得出去说，哦，该死，我又出名了。而且我必须戴上那个愚蠢的声音。我必须戴上那个有趣的步态。而且不，他们朋友的建议和我们的一样重要。而且，而且我不认为他教了他多少关于他父亲名声的事情。我想他只是，他只是非常专注于他正在用他的乐队做的事情。哦，那太棒了。那太棒了。好吧，你们，你们当然培养了一个，就像你说的，你，你的孩子们都去当地，去了当地学校。而且，而且我知道，你知道，在夏天，你和Ed花了很多时间在一起，你们的家庭有点，每个人都在一起。而且有一种那种社区的感觉
and family. Yeah, community is the right word. Yeah. And, and it's, it's really lovely. And, and then there's always all kinds of artists and people coming in and out. But it's never, there's never any pretension. It's kind of like everything's very, I don't know, very, very real. And in a way that's not what you think it would be. It's not this kind of like, you know, up there, it's, it's very grounded. And you see it in your kids and your family. So you can hear in the music too. And you, yeah, of course, it's amazing. It's really, really generous thing to say, because it's the most important thing to us. And we didn't screw up our kids, but we can still try. But thank you. Please keep it going. And your band is a great band. And you started in lockdown
和家庭。是的，社区是正确的词。是的。而且，而且它，它真的很可爱。而且，而且总是有各种各样的艺术家和人进进出出。但它从来没有，从来没有任何虚伪。它有点像一切都非常，我不知道，非常，非常真实。而且以一种不是你认为它会是的方式。它不是这种像，你知道，在那上面，它，它非常扎实。而且你在你的孩子和你的家庭中看到了它。所以你也能在音乐中听到它。而且你，是的，当然，它太棒了。这真是，非常慷慨的话，因为它是对我们最重要的事情。而且我们没有搞砸我们的孩子，但我们仍然可以尝试。但谢谢。请保持下去。而且你的乐队是一个很棒的乐队。而且你是在封锁中开始的
for the right reasons. And we love to listen to you. And there's been some great ones. Will you, talking about breaking back into your old house, when you've sellers remorse on the David Remning cap. So that had me laughing into my cornflakes. I really did really choke on my cornflakes. And, and that's, all of you have kept us sane in insane times. So thank you. Very nice of you. Well, thank you for your contributions to the world. Yeah. Yeah. And your contribution is smart list. Thank you for giving us an hour of your time. It's really, really an honor. It's an honor to meet you. Yeah, for sure. Blessings to you three. Bye-bye. Unto your team. All the best. Bye, Bono. Good luck. See you. Thank you. Bye-bye. Yes. Of course, Bono slammed it. Of course,
出于正当的理由。我们很喜欢听你们说。其中有一些很棒的故事。Will，你谈到当你对David Remning的帽子感到后悔时，潜回你以前的房子。那让我笑得喷出了玉米片。我真的被玉米片呛到了。而且，你们所有人都让我们在疯狂的时代保持理智。所以谢谢你们。你们太好了。好吧，谢谢你们对世界的贡献。是的。是的，你们的贡献就是SmartLess。谢谢你们抽出一个小时的时间。这真的是一种荣幸。见到你们是我的荣幸。是的，当然。祝福你们三位。再见。还有你们的团队。祝一切顺利。再见，Bono。祝好运。再见。谢谢。再见。是的。当然，Bono把笔记本电脑摔了。当然，
Bono slams a laptop. I mean, he's not going to miss a move like that. Did it feel like we went into like a, into like a different area of the space time? Like did we just like go find a little pocket of time? Yeah. And you could have just sat there and listened to him. Well, I mean, I definitely did. You two clearly have done that before with him. I mean, like, it's like a fucking Conan party, fucking Sean's eating with Edge. You're hanging out with Bono. Like, where am I? You know, what I'm doing? I'm like down at Whitsitt hitting balls, you know? Well, maybe stop playing so much fucking golf and get out into the world, man. There's a whole world. I had the good fortune of spending some time with those guys down in the South of France.
Bono摔了笔记本电脑。我的意思是，他不会错过那样的动作。感觉我们是不是进入了时空的另一个区域？就像我们刚刚找到了一个时间的小口袋？是的。你本可以坐在那里听他说话。好吧，我的意思是，我绝对听了。你们两个显然以前和他一起做过这种事。我的意思是，这就像一个该死的Conan派对，该死的Sean在和Edge一起吃饭。你和Bono在一起。就像，我在哪儿？你知道，我在做什么？我像是在Whitsitt打球，你知道吗？好吧，也许别打那么多该死的高尔夫球，去看看外面的世界吧，伙计。有一个广阔的世界。我有幸在法国南部和那些家伙待了一段时间。
I was working nearby and they were very generous and invited me over a bunch. And Eli and I went over a bunch of times. Yeah, it was amazing. And how nice. How nice is Edge, by the way, Edge did one of the most generous thing ever. This huge party and all these people around. And he knows that, that I didn't drink. It's no secret that I've been in and out with, you know, booze over the years and that I don't drink and, and, and, you know, everybody's having a good time. And he went, I said, you know, that somebody offered me a drink. I said, no, no, no, I don't. And he came, but he went into the kitchen himself and comes back out with a tray with like four ice cold bottles of San Pellegrino sparkling water and a glass and stuff. He says, here,
我在附近工作，他们非常慷慨，多次邀请我过去。Eli和我去了好几次。是的，太棒了。而且Edge人真好。顺便说一句，Edge做了有史以来最慷慨的事情之一。在这个巨大的派对上，周围有这么多人。他知道我不喝酒。多年来我断断续续地喝酒，我不喝酒并不是什么秘密，而且，你知道，每个人都玩得很开心。他走过来，我说，你知道，有人给了我一杯酒。我说，不，不，不，我不喝。他来了，但他亲自走进厨房，拿回一个托盘，上面有四瓶冰镇的圣培露气泡水、一个杯子之类的东西。他说，给你，
I got this for you and bubble on if you need it. And a whiskey chaser and some Coke. Coke is still on the table for you, right? Yeah. Oh, a little bit of weed. Oh, what we call fat rails. Fat rails. Yeah. Good for you. Fat rails. And a bag of shrooms. And he just, yeah, but nice guy. Four ice, no booze. But you know, when you, when you were introducing, but it was very generous, but they're both like that. Yeah, they're both like, when you were introducing him, I really did get nervous. I was like, oh my God, this guy's going to be like, who is this? And of course it was huge, it was Bono. And, and the first thing I thought of was like, how many bands, it's so rare now that
如果你需要的话，我给你拿了这个。还有威士忌和可乐。可乐还在桌上给你准备着，对吧？是的。哦，还有一点大麻。哦，我们称之为“大粗卷”。大粗卷。是的。真为你高兴。大粗卷。还有一袋迷幻蘑菇。他只是，是的，真是个好人。四瓶冰水，没有酒。但你知道，当你介绍他时，我真的很紧张。我当时想，天哪，这家伙会想，这是谁？当然，那是大人物，是Bono。我首先想到的是，有多少乐队，现在太罕见了，
the world creates bands that have such longevity like you too. Or, you know, you think of the Rolling Stones or you too. You know what I mean? Yeah. Sean, did you, it's weird that the, why would they, why do you think that they would name the band after a bomber plane? Why do you, why, what do you, did you ever ask edge that? That you too is a bomber? No. Yeah. Yeah. The you too bomber plane. That's not why they named it. Is that why they named it? That's not true. No, it's not. It means you too. Me, him, and you too. You know, like, I thought I was going to get on that. Wait, no, but you know what I mean? Oh yeah. You know what I mean, though, but like, like, how, isn't that wild that we live like now, they don't make them like they used to like, there's,
世界创造了像U2这样长寿的乐队。或者，你知道，你会想到滚石乐队或U2。你知道我的意思吗？是的。Sean，你觉得奇怪吗，为什么他们会用轰炸机来命名乐队？你为什么，你有没有问过Edge？U2是一架轰炸机？没有。是的。是的，U2轰炸机。这不是他们命名的原因。那是他们命名的原因吗？那不是真的。不，不是。它的意思是“你也是”（You too）。我，他，还有你。你知道，就像，我以为我会参与其中。等等，不，但你知道我的意思吗？哦，是的。你知道我的意思，但就像，这不是很疯狂吗，我们现在生活在这样的时代，他们不像过去那样制作音乐了，就像，有，
no, no, he's a proper rock star from a proper super group that doesn't exist. And the other, I have another memory one time. We were out here in Long Island having lunch and I was, Chappy was here and we, I know Chappy gets another mention. She's actually showing up today. I'm really excited to see him. And we come back to the table. Yeah. Chappy and Conan are coming over. We come back to the table. We went out to have a little visit with the men from, from RJ or Reynolds. And we come back to the table and as they're approaching the table, I'm not kidding. The painter who's Julian Schnabel was sitting at the table talking to Bono. Oh no, it's a crazy name job. And as I'm walking back, Bono says to me, hey, Will,
不，不，他是一个真正的摇滚明星，来自一个不存在的真正的超级组合。还有，我有另一个记忆。有一次我们在长岛吃午饭，Chappy也在。我知道Chappy又被提到了。她今天实际上会出现。我很高兴见到他。我们回到桌子旁。是的，Chappy和Conan要过来了。我们回到桌子旁。我们出去拜访了RJ Reynolds的人。我们回到桌子旁，当他们走近桌子时，我不开玩笑。画家Julian Schnabel正坐在桌旁和Bono说话。哦，不，这名字太疯狂了。当我走回来时，Bono对我说，嘿，Will，
we're just having a conversation. What do you think about the idea of like being able to put value on art and actually paying money for art and, you know, value of art? And I go, I'm not Bono, I'm not answering that. You think that I want this to turn into the, the story of the time I got punched in the face by Julian Schnabel? I said, no, thanks. That's a hell of a movie director too. No kidding. Yeah. Now, what were you guys talking about at the beginning? Is he doing some sort of tour with the book where he's going to be alone on stage kind of playing acoustic, kind of like a Springsteen type of show? Thank you. So from his book, Surrender, 40 Songs, One Story, he is, he did a show at the
我们正在谈话。你觉得给艺术定价并为艺术支付金钱，以及艺术的价值，这些想法怎么样？我说，不，Bono，我不会回答那个问题。你以为我想让这变成我被Julian Schnabel打脸的故事吗？我说，不，谢谢。那也是个了不起的电影导演。别开玩笑了。是的。现在，你们刚开始在谈论什么？他是不是要带着这本书进行某种巡演，他会独自在舞台上弹奏原声吉他，有点像Springsteen式的演出？谢谢。所以从他的书《Surrender: 40 Songs, One Story》来看，他在
Beacon and now starting in April of, actually starting April 16th, he's going to be doing his show where he goes and he talks on stage and he does some songs from U2. And he tells stories, excerpts from his books, and then he tells stories and interacts with the audience. He did it this fall and, you know, people went crazy for it. And so he's going to, he's decided to come back and he's going to do more shows there. And it's really exciting. I mean, more shows at the Beacon or is he going to go around the Beacon? And then around, yeah, it's just been like, the reviews of it are amazing. People say it's just incredible. And like he said, he's sort of sanctioned by the band because he's up there himself doing it. And
Beacon剧院做了一场演出，现在从4月开始，实际上是从4月16日开始，他将进行他的演出，他会去舞台上谈话，并演唱一些U2的歌曲。他讲述故事，书中的摘录，然后他讲述故事并与观众互动。他在今年秋天做了这个演出，你知道，人们为之疯狂。所以他决定回来，他要在那里做更多的演出。这真的很令人兴奋。我的意思是，在Beacon做更多演出，还是他要在Beacon周围巡演？然后在周围，是的，评论太棒了。人们说这简直不可思议。就像他说的那样，他算是得到了乐队的认可，因为他自己在那上面表演，而且
Edge was at his, at that show that he did at the Beacon. I don't know if Adam and Larry were, but anyway, pretty cool stuff. Man, I'd like to see that. Yeah. Again, I'm someone, you know, it's funny. Like I really, I've always been a fan of the band and their music and all those guys, the guys I just mentioned, Larry and Adam and Edge and Bono collectively, U2, just such a fan. And they, for all of us, their music has played different parts of our lives over the years. But it was, I think the thing I'm the most in awe about is his activism and the what he's done to actually use that to not just reflect it in the songs and the content, deliver powerful message in his songs, but actually go out and do it in the way that he has. Get off his butt and do
Edge在他Beacon的那场演出中。我不知道Adam和Larry是否也在，但无论如何，很酷的东西。伙计，我想看那个。是的。再说一次，我是那种人，你知道，这很有趣。我一直都是这个乐队和他们的音乐的粉丝，所有那些家伙，我刚才提到的那些家伙，Larry、Adam、Edge和Bono，总的来说，U2，我真是太喜欢了。他们，对我们所有人来说，他们的音乐在过去几年里在我们生活中扮演了不同的角色。但我认为我最敬畏的是他的行动主义，以及他所做的事情，不仅是在歌曲和内容中反映出来，在歌曲中传递强有力的信息，而且实际上走出去，以他那种方式去做。从屁股上站起来去做
it. Dude, right after Band-Aid, he went to Africa. He and Ali went to Africa and worked in Africa. And he's just all the stuff that he's done over the years. I mean, just countless stories of shit that he's done that people don't even know about. And between writing and touring and stuff, it's like kind of amazing. It's pretty sick. And then I think about, you know, Jason at the fucking grade working on his seven iron and just thinking like, why am I finishing here and the face is not square. I'm not even thinking about helping cleaning up the balls afterwards. No. It's like, you know, I'm just like, he's out there traveling to Africa feeding people, you know. You don't even pick up your own fucking golf. In fact, I'm annoyed that I have to look at all those fucking loose
伙计，在Band-Aid之后，他去了非洲。他和Ali去了非洲，在非洲工作。多年来他所做的一切。我的意思是，无数关于他所做的事情的故事，人们甚至都不知道。在写作和巡演之间，这真是太神奇了。这太疯狂了。然后我想，你知道，Jason在那个该死的练习场练习他的7号铁杆，只是想，为什么我在这里收杆，杆面不平？我甚至没想过帮忙清理后面的球。不。就像，你知道，我只是觉得，他在外面去非洲喂饱人们，你知道。你甚至不捡起你自己的该死的高尔夫球。事实上，我很恼火，我不得不看着所有那些该死的散落在
balls out there in the range. I want a clean range to hit to. You're feeding the pond the balls. Me. I'd love for him to write a song about that. Why don't you write a song it's called, ready? Bonnet is thinking about like, how can I, what can I do next to save the world? And Sean's thinking like, how big is the biggest bag of Skittles? Like, do they make a 10 pounder? Because I could really hit those. So when he comes back out to do a show in April, do you think you can dust off this, this friendship Willie and give him a text? Because I don't want to have to buy the tickets. Bye. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Rob Armjolf, Bennett Barbaco,
练习场上的球。我想要一个干净的练习场来击球。你在喂池塘里的球。我。我很乐意让他写一首歌关于那个。你为什么不写一首歌，叫作，准备好了吗？Bono在想，我接下来能做什么来拯救世界？而Sean在想，最大的彩虹糖袋有多大？他们有10磅装的吗？因为我真的能吃掉那些。所以当他在四月回来演出时，你觉得你能掸掉这段友谊的灰尘，给Willie发个短信吗？因为我不想买票。再见。SmartLess是由Rob Armjolf、Bennett Barbaco和Michael Grant Terry手工制作的100%有机艺术品。SmartLess。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
and Michael Grant Terry. SmartLess. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
SmartLess。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。